well she is on her way back from Miami
don't worry she's soon to return it's me
Christine Grace uh if you don't know me
by now I am a talent here at the
audacity Network um so make sure you go
subscribe to my YouTube channel @
Christine gra Smith um we recently did
some Street interviews uh at the
Manchester boxing Mach oh what is going
on thanks sorry about that
uh we recently did some Street
interviews at the Manchester boxing
match Logan Paul did and danis KSI and
Tommy Fury so go check out my channel if
you want to see some Street interviews
from there um in other news couple of
other announcements uh courtesy of the
audacity Network store we have the women
shouldn't vote t-shirts available now
there super soft material and the
ultimate babe magnet guaranteed to get
all of the women looking in your
direction so click the link in the
description to get your women shouldn't
vote t-shirts
um and of course if you're not already
subscribed to this channel just pearly
things make sure you hit that subscribe
button and yeah keep up to date with all
of the pregame shows and of course P
daily so today I am joined by a lovely
panel of guests and today we're going to
talk about the topic of promiscuity
promiscuity uh more importantly the
topic of our hose worthless in today's
society so I'm going to go around the
room first of all um and ask you all to
introduce yourself go ahead yes hi there
uh my name is Dena I'm 30 years old I'm
from London um and
yeah hi my name is Emma I'm 23 I'm
originally from Australia but now living
in
London hi my name is Iola I am 22 years
old and I live in
London yeah go ahead oh yeah it's AJ's
reactions uh I rea the stuff oh okay
have you got a YouTube channel yeah Tik
Tok Instagram little bit everything cool
yo yo guys your boy Romeo the plug
official Romeo 27 I'm outside I'm back
at the audacity Network yes I'm part of
the network and yeah I'm here let's go
amazing um and what's everyone's
relationship status I forgot to ask oh I
single [__] sake single same engaged oh
congratulations how how long have you
been
engaged H am I in a relationship um
what's that I mean something man I
guess
okay anyway so yeah the topic today is
is promiscuity a form of empowerment for
young women um not just young women
women of all ages really um so I want to
go around the room and I want to get all
your guys thoughts is promiscuity so
being promisc uous whether it be sexual
partners or whether it just be online um
is it a form of female empowerment or
does it enhance sexual objectification
I'm going to start here and go around um
I mean I think it's defined differently
you know I mean each woman in each
different generation can see something
like being promiscuous differently yes
it can be used as a form of art to get
attention uh in reality or you know be a
certain way but I think it's now
completely changed with the younger
generation especially with social media
coming on board that has changed the
game completely because you can compare
it to 50 years ago someone can be have a
natural way with their physicality with
their words with their way of being now
with social media I think it's be be
it's become normalized in a sense I mean
I don't agree with it or disagree with
it I think it's a part of a woman's
nature um I come from a psychology
backgrounds but it just kind of
analyzing I think it's within women's
nature to natur be like that in a way
you think it's within women's nature to
be promiscuous but yes but not not in a
way of sexualizing it cuz you're you're
when we say being promiscuous we in
instantly associate it being sexual
sexual right can it be something that's
nonsexual being promiscuous well I think
the definition of promiscuous
specifically regards sexual behavior
right um so I mean do you want to
elaborate on on what kind of behavior
you're talking about because yeah I mean
it can I mean men can perceive it
differently I guess women can perceive
it differently um there is that sexual
connotation to it but the element of it
being over sexualized has changed
recently so I mean yeah like I said I
think women tend to do it it's become
normalized because of social media I
don't agree with it but I I think
there's a nature there's something
within us that naturally is like that
may it be for evolutional reasons or
whatever what is it that you don't agree
with in what aspect which B you said
that promis it has been enhanced by yeah
what do I not agree with it because it's
become normalized and why why do you
think that's a bad thing uh I mean it's
it's a bad thing because a woman doesn't
know what she's doing from a young age
and can be put in positions that she can
be endanger may it be in on online may
it be physically you know out if you're
out on a bar and you're flirting with a
guy um things can escalate I don't think
women really know what it is themselves
at a certain age Point okay interesting
we'll come back to okay yes it's similar
to what she said um I think it's it's
very much so of who perceives what so
women that like like to like you know
with a whole body confidence and so
forth so a lot of the time people like
to show like if especially if they say
they work out a lot and they want to
show like their before and after
pictures or they want to show their
bikinis want to show their like their
body like I I think women tend to do
that because they want to show what
they're proud of whereas if a woman's
always posting photos of the themselves
M El with you know their bums out and
their bodies out men may may perceive
that as what like a oh she's you know
trying to get love male attention she
trying to oversexualize your and maybe
that not be the case I mean I guess one
could argue that do they have to share
it on a public Instagram profile if
they're proud of it can't they just
share it with their friends and family I
mean do you think that that comes into
it at all or do you think that people
should just accept that people want to
share that kind of thing I think if this
was maybe like 20 years ago that would
have been yeah you keep that between
your friends your family the ones that
close to you but now social media is
just taking over the world completely so
even if you're going out for a dinner
you want to show the fries that you're
eating people post that if you want to
show where wherever you're saying people
post that like everything's posted now
so there's no sense of privacy the only
time someone's private is when they
choose to be private but a lot of the
time people don't want to be private
anymore why why do you think that is why
don't you why do you think people I just
think that's just the way that that
social media is kind of just made it
especially for the younger generation
that's all they know so like people that
may be in the like the early 20s to late
late 20s early 30s they understands that
social media wasn't a massive thing at
when I was five or six years old how old
are you again sorry 23 23 so I I don't
think social media was a massive thing
till I was maybe like 13 14 15 yeah I'm
the same age as you I'd say about the
same so around that age it became a
massive thing but whereas the children
now at the age of five six all they know
is social media Tik Tok this and that
YouTube whatever so from that age
onwards that's all they're going to know
is just post this post that especially
with parents giving that to them at a
young age is just the Privacy starts
from a young age so
okay yeah I would personally need first
of all the definition of this word
because I don't understand what it is uh
so to to be promiscuous um is to be sort
of very sexually out there um so for
example oh there we go we've got the
definition great king is on it today
can't say that word promiscuity how you
say having or involving many sexual
partners not restricted to one sexual
partner or few sexual partners not
restricted to one class sort of
person all right and what was the
question again uh so is promiscuity
female promiscuity specifically does it
promote female empowerment or does it
promote sexual objectification of
women well I think that's a difficult
question especially in our society now
to resp response if it's right or not I
will not do that tonight but what I will
say is that in
um as a in a biologic way or scientific
way it tends to be more destructive for
a woman to have this kind of behavior
but at the end of the day you are you
you do what you want what you feel is
make you happy and uh yeah that's all I
have to say about
this H
um if we ju just ask me the question one
more time so promiscuity female
promiscuity does it promote female
empowerment or does it promote the
objectification of women all right so
essentially is female promiscuity good
or bad for women so look if you want to
feel empowered by throwing your cheeks
around do your thing that's entirely up
to you I'm not going to judge my only
problem with calling it female
empowerment is you get to the point
where you want to be loved by somebody
you want to have good relationships if
you've been throwing your cheeks around
and a person turns around to you and
says
hey I don't want you cuz you threw your
cheeks around but what if you're deeply
in love when you don't care you're not
going to you're not going to wife you're
not going to wife your hold are you
that's that sounds like that have done
that there are men that have wied a porn
star for example oh that's how long does
that last I don't know I'm just I'm just
throwing it out that CU obviously men
prefer women that are let's say less
sexually active whatever which makes
sense and I agree with that ideology but
the reality of today is a whole
different story and so what do we do why
cuz I don't know society's a bit [__]
up it has been for years and years and
years and each generation keeps getting
worse so here we are having this
conversation you know as I said
if you feel like throwing around your
cheeks yes is female
empowerment do your thing what it can't
matter has nothing to do with me just
don't be upset if the man that you want
to courau says hey I don't want a
million
bodies don't be upset why is it that the
guys care so much about body count about
promiscuity what is it that that's a
turnoff because a key that can open many
doors it's a master key M preach you get
it let let let that one sink in right
there okay but if it's the other way
around it's just get it's just a [__]
lock if any key can open it's a [__]
lock no I think you're defining that way
it's different it's different it's
different for women and men like you
can't like you always look at a woman's
body count in it I don't know what it is
but that body count actually does matter
on on a woman's part for men it's
different is it
is it just the thought of that woman
that you're seeing or dating or
interested in the fact that they've been
with so many men is that just offputting
just another man having her hands on her
is that what it is is that like a confus
are you are you fight are you fighting
I'm asking questions both so quick
question are you fighting right now cuz
obviously you're pushing back against us
are you fighting for women to throw the
cheeks around no I'm not but I
understand the the male psyche behind
that do you throw your cheeks around
serious Endeavor that's a private
question oh God damn
it
but you see this is my problem so yeah
you're obviously saying oh yeah it's
fine no I'm not saying it's fine you're
not saying it's fine I'm not listen
you're not saying it's fine I'm not
saying it's fine but I'm trying to
understand it I think she's trying to
pay Devil's Advocate just to see how
strong your story is yeah exactly is
that is that what we doing how strong
your justification is cuz that's what do
you mean my justification is literally
if you want to throw cheeks around I get
what you're saying I I completely hear
what you're saying and I want to know
any of the ladies on the couch do do you
agree or do you disagree that it's
different for for men and
women I disagree cuz uh I think that
there's
obviously a difference between men and
women but uh as a man it I mean it can
look as well negative that you are
sleeping around and some some of us
don't want you to so what what's the
problem with a guy being promiscuous
from the female
perspective as it shows first of all
lack of confidence confidence lack of
control uh lack of
leadership and yeah just a
general man's body you said Community
dick is lack of confidence
yeah exp expand that one for me please
just just just let let's let's get into
it expand that one for me as a my point
of view is
that a man is supposed to lead in
general mhm biologically naturally or
whatever and
uh I don't even know how to really put
it out in in English it's a little bit
difficult for me but you not being able
to make one woman happy and you need the
validation all those women by not
committing to
something it's already a sign of lack of
confidence cuz one woman already it's a
lot of work it's a lot of commitment it
it's a lot of thing in a daily basis
with kids it's like it's again another
but are you referring to a uh in the
context of a relationship or do you just
mean a guy who sleeps around with a lot
of women so both of way I would say a
guy who is in a relationship or is not
um it can it can as if you dig them dig
down to it it can just mean that the
person lack of confidence Sor sorry do
you mean do you mean lack of control or
lack of confidence both control and
confidence leadership and
self-esteem if a if a man is clapping
multiple cheeks he's clearly got enough
confidence to approach a lot of these
women to even get in that situation in
general I say for woman as well if she
has the capacity to bend down all those
men she has hold on hold on hold on you
have a lot of confidence too I
don't hey it's a bit left in it but what
I think you mean is that the man has
just a lack of self-control I don't
think you mean he has a lack of
confidence because a lack of confidence
would not allow a man to approach a
multitude of women what I mean is lack
of confidence and control but both of
them how can it be a lack of confidence
if a man is able to approach the women
and bed them I mean is it possible
actually to make fully happy a woman one
woman is is very difficult so you're
talking about lack of women are wise
very differently unfortunately you know
I mean our our hormones are very
different I understand what you're
saying
biologically it is what it is you know
mean testerone in men functions
differently right and then women can
turn around and and say well actually I
don't like guys are inexperienced I
don't know what they're doing but then
at the same time they can argue the
other side of wow you know so it's a
difficult place it's a difficult
question to really answer to be honest
with yeah but at the end of the day um
that we even consider it that it plays
as well in the mind uh in the cycle of a
man to continue to do this kind of but
men boys don't become men until later
stage and women you have to understand
that as well physically and mentally
ladies let let me ask you this question
ladies would you date a virgin no would
you date a virgin no well yeah that's my
point I was making would you date a
virgin yes or no it's depend for flip
sake man well in the middle what you you
are straight no why not you want a man
of confidence no at the same time I
think you know I feel like in a
relationship obviously the sexual part
of it is quite important may not be in
all relationships but I think a majority
is so I think especially
say I think in in that sense you want to
be somewhat satisfied and obviously like
some people like I feel like a guy would
like to say a virsion cuz like obviously
it's like oh she's got no body count
like she doesn't have a body count I can
teach her what to do whereas women like
again we like to kind of be led as well
so in that sense is like you know if
you're acting masculine all day you
don't want to be acting masculine in the
bedroom with your man like that's just
that's just I that's just not on sorry
but no that makes sense and and you also
said definitely not is it the same kind
of Reason um I just don't have patience
to be teaching other people I want to be
taught not in in a sexual aspect I mean
in a general aspect if if I'm interested
in a man it's because I want to be led
let's say knowledge energy whatever it
is a virgin because he is a virgin is
then attached with let's say experience
socially uh whatever do you I mean there
is they at a certain point not because
of the sexual aspect of it because of
their point in then life mhm that itti
she wants a man of confidence yeah but
nothing STS as well that
virion that we're talking about um
doesn't have the capacity to become a
man no he can become a man but I'm sure
he'll meet another virgin and they'll
get on do you I mean everybody vibrates
in different energies and there are
different points in their lives you know
there is an exception in every single
societ I think's C for you want someone
with a clean slate what does that mean
so so as as these lot said they don't
want a data version but you were a
little bit Melancholy in regards to it
you technically wouldn't mind depend
can depending on the
person all the factor that's uh you know
that that makes the person depending on
it I'm going to say yes or no okay so
you don't mind having to teach someone
that's in experience you don't mind it
that's okay I mean it's depend like I
said it's depend there's a lot of factor
that comes with it so what are the sum
of factors that come into it what does
it depend on first of all um I will
respect the the the man and uh
regardless of him being a
virgin um having leadership skills being
a person who is confident and when that
is on point I believe that when it comes
to the sexual Port even though he is
um unexp I don't know how to say that
even though he doesn't have experience
he will have a lot of confidence to uh
get to understand and maybe have more
patient and also better understanding
than a person who already [__] up um
his um mind with u sorry corn and uh um
all those metor experiences yeah I mean
the porn subjects aside uh I think
you're I think you're making a bit of a
mistake with the differences between men
and women so a guy could sleep with I am
very clear with what I'm saying maybe
it's the way I'm putting out but I'm not
changing my mind that's fair enough but
the point that I'm trying to make is
that men and women are very different
when it comes to sex a guy could sleep
with a lot of girls and have no
emotional connection to any of those
girls whatsoever I understand that point
but I'm still saying that it it's still
detrimental you know it's a fact that
what you just said is a proved by
science but it's a fact as well that uh
on a long term if you continue on that
road it will still have the same effect
that will it can have on a woman not the
same thing but you know is I will never
say that um a woman should not sleep
around and a man can because it's false
but that they have less effect on a man
is just proven by
science did you say that's proven by
science yeah biologically it's proven no
she she's agreeing that uh
men I think you're talking about what
I'm talking about which is pair bonding
so men's ability to pair born does start
to decline but it's at a very different
rate to women so a woman it's a about
five bodies so after a woman has gone
above five bodies uh her ability to pair
bond to a partner is decreased for a man
it's like a way higher number I don't
have the specific number but it it might
be something like 50 or something um but
obviously that's because men
biologically are built to spread their
seed whereas for women it's a bit
different although I did see a study
recently that suggested women are more
polyamorous but that's I haven't looked
into it so
we anyway I want to revert back to you
all mentioned earlier when I mentioned
promiscuity you all pretty much spoke
about social media um so I want to delve
more into the social media aspect um
does social media promote promiscuity do
you think do you think it encourages
people to be promiscuous online
absolutely I mean when you look at the
history sex as all sold right anything
that's been sexualized even let's say in
the 50s with cigarettes majority of the
adverts had sexy ladies smoking because
it It's associated with an oral form do
you know mean smok smoking um so
sexuality has always been a part of
let's say CES or driving a motive or
changing our minds or perspectives now
social media when that came into into
place gradually in the beginning it
wasn't I mean I'm 30 years old in the
beginning we didn't really post that
many you know soury photos and all of a
sudden when the business aspect became a
part of Instagram and I'm sure you we
all remember when you know Instagram was
just simple posting things now you've
got you can sell things it's changed
completely now it's marketed on
vulnerable women in my opinion that has
now that have now come on social media
they've grown up with with a let's say a
young mindset they are young they're
seeing older women more attractive women
doing and having a certain Behavior
pattern and they've thought that's okay
because their parents don't know what
they're looking at or their their
friends and their peers have the same
mentality so I think each generation has
grown up with the with normalizing
showing your body on social media and
now it's obviously capitalized and
Instagram Facebook everything has is now
making money from women posting sexy
photos and then you can argue yes women
want to do that but unfortunately
they're not realizing that they're
teaching the Next Generation the wrong
thing and yeah I think it's been
capitalized hugely what what is it
that's wrong about it in your opinion I
mean what's selling um your body online
mhm what's wrong with it I mean I think
it should be I mean there's a lot of
things wrong wrong with it I think
morally it's not correct and that's my
simplest answer just morally it's not
correct
okay yeah definitely I think so like um
basing on what she said just then like
sex cells so I think especially now cuz
Instagram is a lot of people and
businesses promote a lot of their you
know Brands and so forth on it sex cells
so they're going to want to have
good-look people or you know girls that
are kind of you know attractive and so
forth may not be to that extent and
obviously we're not speaking about
business and in this we're speaking
about promiscuity but since when I was a
child till now the way that you know
social media is it's yeah there's a
massive massive change in what people
actually generally share um and if even
if you just go in your like even if you
count 10 posts eight out of 10 posts
someone naked or there's someone you
know showing something um if even if
it's not themselves it's something
that's a bit more you know on the sexual
sides of of of anything so and what do
you think of that do you think that that
that's a good thing or a bad thing just
in your personal opinion not whether
it's you know the public opinion what do
you make of that again I think I think I
think it is it does play on morals as
well some people may feel confident to
show a lot some people may not it's
insecurities as well you have to
remember women we all have a lot of
insecurities so I think a lot of younger
women are going out their way for
validation through likes through of
course you know people wake up and
they're like oh how many likes do I have
and that for me is absurd for me it's
absurd that someone can rely their
happiness or their self-confidence on
the amount of views and likes that they
have that for me is a very alien thing
but it's a real thing yeah definitely so
the motive is now connected with views
and likes and posting more so it it's
correct so it's basically like awarding
unconsciously is being like a woman's
being awarded bu likes by posting more
and more and more so it it carries on in
a way yeah I also think in in a way a
lot of um this generation self worth um
selfworth comes from social media so
it's like I I want to see how much I can
get I want to see the likes or views
whatever I can get and that if I can hit
this amount or if I can get change my
mood but if I get if I post something
that gets 50 likes that would be like
wow that's low well in this generation
it is when you're seeing other people
other celebrities other influencers or
just even normal people getting 6 700
and you're posting a photo that you
think you look nice in and you're
getting 50 and you're comparing it to
someone else who's got you know a
different photo they're going to be like
oh PE girls especially love to compare
themselves unfortunately that's just how
it is they're always going to compare
themselves to Kylie Jenner or whoever so
I think just even just a subconscious
thing that we just generally will always
compare yeah ad you're you're you're
laughing along there what's your
thoughts no just because I couldn't
really relate with it but yeah I
understand cuz um I do not compare
myself with kindly gener I believe we're
too different but unfortunately majority
of of women are I don't either I don't
follow celebrities I don't really care
about that world but unfortunately young
you have to think about other people and
unfortunately it's become a real thing
of our society where what col gener says
and does affect people that for me is
absurd but it is the reality that we
live in unfortunately yeah AEL can I ask
you one more time what is the question
um so the question is does social media
promote female promiscuities does it
encourage it of course yeah as social
media is definitely a PL a platform to
promote a lot of things businesses or
wherever you want to promote and um I
mean I believe that when it comes to
sexuality it is a great way to do
publicity Whenever Whatever Whatever
topic it is so um yeah I believe that
the social media is becoming more and
more sexual and um and do you think
that's a good or a bad
thing yeah
um obviously the there is some danger in
there cuz some people will say that it's
good because um there is positivity in
there but at the same time it will come
as well with some recation or how they
say it with some birs
questions so I I want to uh before
coming to the lads to get your opinion
on this um I want to get your guys
thoughts on body positivity what does it
mean to you and and what's your thoughts
of
it um what body
positivity um I mean because we hear
this a lot with when we talk is this
what people are using these days to
say cuz I haven't really heard it in
this ter so a lot of people who come on
here um and uh obviously when hosting
she might put it slightly different to
how I put it but you know they they say
you know I I like to show my body online
and I like to share it with the world
because it's body positivity and it's
this whole idea of uh confidence and
self-love and selfworth um at least
that's unfortunately we're being led a
lot by a lot of mentally ill people
because when you look at a lot of
agendas that are completely destroying
people's
morals this can fall into that same
category now someone
being sexual and promiscuous online that
is then awarded in a way unconsciously
to that person for them to believe that
it's a correct behavior that goes to
show you mean a lot of people have a lot
to work within themselves in my opinion
so that comes from a lot of trauma a
woman that is very okay with that has to
be so delusional in a form of protection
so they've come from trauma or they've
come from something that they have to
they become that deluded for them to
feel positive for showing their body
online you know and that I just look at
it in a in a very vulnerable way cuz I
feel sorry for these women it's not that
I attack them I don't look down at them
I don't I don't agree with what they're
doing like only fans girls I don't
disagree with what they're doing but
it's a shame that they're doing that
because they don't realize how
traumatized or hurt and how much healing
they need to do for them to actually
grasp the idea of them to think about
what it's like in the future them
looking back on their actions cuz you
can't undo especially anything on online
line they made loads of money though
yeah but money comes and goes that's the
problem people don't understand money is
motivated money is can be evil in my
opinion depends on the person I think it
can be a very evil thing money comes and
goes that's not what life is all about
making money it isn't so so if you
exploit a behavior and you make loads of
money off of it but I wouldn't exploit a
behavior that's incorrect I'm not
talking about you but I'm saying with
the only fans girls if you if you
exploit a behavior and you make loads of
money off it and all of a sudden the
behav like you've grown out of it and
now you're in a different state where
your mind isn't all too there yeah
exactly imag who is who is really to
blame for that is
it or or is it you like like where does
what I want to know is where does the
accountability come in like when when do
we when do we look at ourselves and be
like ra this madness happened to me in
my life MH but I'm not going to go and
do an absolute Madness to other people
because it can potentially affect
everybody it doesn't make any sense
where do we where do we get to the part
where we're like okay this madness
happened to you we get it mhm that
doesn't mean you go and then do the same
Madness to other people where does the
accountability come in in this situation
there's so many factors I think I think
socially economically there's so many
things that are in play to a woman's
when a woman for example if a woman has
children and and she's a single mother
okay but at the same time yes she needs
to feed her kids but if she really
wanted to feed her kids should get up
and work cut ass off in my opinion I
come from a refugee family that came
here from a war I know what it is like
to come from nothing you know what I
mean I know what what that means so
unfortunately women are seeing this as a
easy option but not really understanding
the consequences in the future that's
you you said that you uh you know that
it's a shame and that they've been
through trauma and all of that which I I
I agree I I think ultimately that
there's a void in themselves that
they're trying to F with something
outside of themselves without knowing
unfortunately most of the time I thought
that for a long time okay I'm now
starting to believe it's it's just
willful ignorance um but oh okay perhaps
we won't get into a philosophical debate
my my question my question for you is is
uh you said you know it's a shame it's
trauma all of that stuff so why do you
not disagree with it you said you don't
you don't disagree with them doing
it I don't listen someone's opinion I
can't understand someone's background of
doing it so I can't judge somebody on
that basis of me just understanding
certain facts about an individual I
don't agree with it in a whole in in a
bigger perspective I don't agree with
women selling their bodies online or so
you do disagree with I I do disagree
with what women are doing yes right okay
but I'm just trying understand why but
at the same time I do the same thing I
try and psychoanalyze everything but I
think ultimately in society the only way
we're going to move forward is if we
have clear definitions about things
because I think at the moment we live in
a world where everything has become and
as much as I hate the word fluid
everything is a mess right now and we
seem to have lost the definitions to
things and I think you know we seem to
have gone overboard with this concept of
Tolerance the idea of you know you can
do what you want and Live and Let Live
it's like okay well how far does that go
cuz if we stop judging each other how do
we decide who's a criminal but those
people are then affecting our
environment our do you I mean people in
general online somebody at that do you I
mean let's say someone has loads of
followers and has younger women
following them listening to their
[__] and their absolute nonsense
that is then affecting us not directly
but indirectly yeah and it's affecting
the Next Generation absolutely and where
is the stop but where again where does
the accountability come in I'm going to
ask this again because all of us in here
probably listen that individual has to
take accountability for themselves no
but this this is why I'm saying it
sounds like it sounds like we're making
excuses here because when we're
listening to rap music the vast majority
of people that listen to rap music
aren't going out and doing Road not
going out stabbing people they're not
going out shooting people they're not
going out doing booting they're not
they're not going out
scamming defitely having a great time
one second one second they're not going
out doing all the all of these different
things no no no no this you're talking
about a small minority of people that
are doing it otherwise if a large
majority of people that listen to rap
again one of the biggest genres in the
world the whole world would be in mus
music and a woman's body are two
different things no buty what I'm trying
what I'm trying to show you is where
does the accountability come in what I'm
trying to show you is I'm trying to give
you well what's your opinion where do
you think I think he's talking about the
fact that you said there's multiple
factors that come into it and you said
you know that
effect what he's trying to say is that
ultimately it is the woman's decision if
she decides to do that this what I'm
saying like when it when it comes to man
listening to all this music they're not
going out and doing all this type of
stuff there's a vast majority of men
that listen to rap music that don't go
on to be murderers drug deers all type
of stuff in general MH so where do we
like where do we like look at the
situation and be like bro there needs to
be some accountability taken for the
person again I completely understand
that you might have a situation that's
completely messed up every single person
not every single person but a lot of
people have worse situations than you
and they have not gone into doing things
that are going to denigrate their own
community so I'm going to ask again when
do we say to the people that are doing
all of this stuff where's your
accountability I get your hurt that's
fine I understand your hurt I understand
think people have done madnesses to you
but there's also a bunch of other people
that have been through those same things
and instead of them going and
denigrating their Community what do they
do they try to be martyrs to make sure
that things like that don't happen to
other people they try to educate people
they try to teach people wagan this that
and blah blah blah but when it comes to
us talking about like you know women and
their bad behavior it's like we we it's
like we just can't say hey just be
accountable just stop yeah be
accountable you I get it your life might
have been mad but bro you selling your
cheeks on on fans for less than a Big
Mac is not my problem what are we doing
here yeah what are we doing here why why
why EXC delusional Do's delusion and
being I want to believe this for a
really long time just stupidity should
just basically just loads of stupid
people have just affected our society is
just what it comes down isn't stupid a
person from accountability not ours no
I'm saying isn't stupidity a personal
problem I don't know they just need to
be I don't know I'm right I'm just
saying stupidity is a personal problem
if you're being stupid is a personal
problem making decision have a question
for the people who are talking about
account accountability yeah um do you
mean that those women who do this kind
of things or this kind of work they are
not taking account of me like they they
are not conscious that they are doing it
or what do you mean about they're
conscious but they're in delusion
they're conscious but what I'm trying to
say is if I go out God forbid and I've
had a bad day at work and I punch
someone in the face regardless whether
not I had a bad day at work I still
punch someone in the face that's what
I'm talking about in terms of
accountability so don't go out do your
Madness because we've seen a lot of only
fans turn reverts right now yeah they're
getting to the point where Co is done
now sorry bid is done now whatever it is
yeah that's all done now and the man
they ain't buying the only fans no more
they're not doing that no more do you
get me they've got things to do they've
actually got to go work x y and Zed and
now you see a bunch of reverts that were
like oh no let me throw that ass in a
circle and and on online blah blah going
oh I found Jesus and I've come back to
Jesus
I wish I didn't do I wish I didn't do
this and they're trying to warn people
against it and it's like okay cool
that's beautiful you've got into the
they're [__] and then they try to play
you see what I'm saying and it's like
it's like but when you when when when
when the price of the fans is going down
yeah yeah it's not remember the fans is
not 30 40 bucks you know it's not none
of them things them there 69 it's a Big
Mac $699 it's a Big Mac $5.99 so so when
when when the price starts going from a
Big Mac to a Happy Meal mhm 199 29 you
you lost the the confidence that you had
that was up here when you had a bunch of
different since doing X Y and Z is now
completely down here who is to blame in
that IM how you say didn't you say
earlier that you you're you're not going
to judge you can do what you want I
don't judge my only thing is don't
complain have you ever subscribed
no The Hub is free you know oh yeah the
the H is free you
knowen you know you know what you know
only fans does so well it's because and
and it's a bit it's a bit merked as well
it's like or used to it's the it's the
um how can I explain it it's the fact
that you can't get someone that you want
that makes people subscribe to only fans
because they can go to the hub and get
all the content that they want but some
man them are out here and they're just
simps for this specific person and
that's the reason why only fans does so
well again only fans is a trap was a
trap for vulnerable people to then to be
capitalized on that's how I see it it's
just who's the vulnerable person in the
scenario that women young women or no
matter what age they are women that what
about the men who are losing their money
hold on do you mean the people that put
their email address in their first name
and their last name and their Bank
details to get money listen vulnerable
people aren't going to process and see
the baits we might from this perspective
hold they they literally fell into a
very obvious trap to get into it to
making quick money that's how they
perceived it to survive or to make money
or whatever I see that as a trap I I
feel like the platform only fans was a
trap for aot vulnerable women hey if if
if if the Trap has five different steps
I'm sorry you might have deserved it in
the if you put in your first name your
last name your email address your bank
details you then got to create the page
you got a post content and then you got
to take the content and you got to post
it on other social medas mean like if
you mean to tell me you got trapped
after seven steps I'm saying the
platform itself the existence of
whatever only fans represents was set up
for a trap to capitalize on women from
women people winningly sign up why are
we I'm not saying that they didn't know
what they're doing I'm talking about the
actual business concept it's not a trap
if you know it's not a trap if you're
will a trap for vulnerable woman a woman
that thinks okay hold on let me when a
woman's delusional she's not going to
think properly is she she's going to be
like okay cool I see an opportunity to
make money let me go and sign up let me
do what I have to do you're not
understanding what I mean by trap I'm
saying why can't they go and get a
normal job they should that's my
point whole business setup of what only
fans represents if you think about it it
was it was initially created knowing
targeting certain women but again aren't
you taking away from the accountability
of the women to realize that they're the
ones who they are realizing but they're
not realizing it to the full extent
until it's too late now that you're
saying there's a lot of women that have
come out of it saying but that this what
I'm saying that's a them problem so
again I asked the question where does
the accountability come in I think I
think most of them take take
accountability with what they're doing
and I think they're very conscious of
what they're doing so the problem with
accountability I still didn't get it cuz
I I never saw a woman that do certain
kind of jobs uh coming on the internet
and start acting like a victim I don't
don't I believe that she's conscious
about what she's doing and she's she's
probably proud of it and it's just you
know confident in what she doing the
accountability comes in when you see
these women that do only find and all of
that and then they come out and they say
they deserve a certain kind of man all
right so you you fail to realize that
the moment you get into something like
that you don't then deserve what you
think you do no matter how how confident
in yourself you feel no matter how well
you think you are a 10 or whatever the
reality is you you deserve what you get
in life and you deserve what you get
from the actions that you do in life so
whenever I see women come out and say oh
yeah yeah I did only F and this and that
but I still deserve a man that makes six
figures that can provide for me and do
all L this and that it just shows me
that you you don't have accountability
and you don't even you're not even self
aware to yeah delusional to realize what
you've put yourself
into so I have a question do only fans
models models models I love how
individual hold on wait hold on sexy
models girls who basically haul
themselves out online for money do they
deserve the same kind of men that girls
who don't do are they entitled to the
same type of
man as I would say it's possible now so
you think a girl who
has literally gotten completely butt
naked online for as much as we said a
Big Mac Mill you you think that can't
believe that that's the same as a girl
who hasn't you think that they can get
the same kind of man can you repeat
again the question cuz I feel like
didn't follow so a girl who does only
fans mhm so gets naked online for the
same amount of money as a burger mhm you
think she's entitled to the same man as
SE girl who hasn't done that like a N9
to-5
woman you think that they're entitled to
the same
man I mean it's depend for examp for
example yourself compared to your own
friends girl are you both entitled to
the same guy it can be
possible see this this is the problem
but now if you want to look at it from a
man's point of view if you had a son
would you want him to date a woman that
been putting her body
online I I was give again the same
reason because um it depend if the woman
is let's let's leave it depends I'm
saying I'm giving my response and my
response is that if that girl is uh is
doing it as said that she is doing it
and uh personally the way I see things
is going uh with the type of content she
is putting out I'm not comfortable with
it no but if she was doing it and uh
there was a lot of time that passed or
maybe she is into something else and I
feel like men are so short temper they
don't look at the details they just look
at the obvious things it's either you're
only fans or you're not you're the
normal girl or know we have noral
means we even we're being too we're
trying to get into I'm I'm just saying
if you had a son and you heard that he's
dating a girl who has been having sex
online selling her body online and he
comes home and tells you Mom I want to
marry this girl would you let that would
you be happy with that decision if I
have a valuable reason
that no I'm not look you're trying to
make is a simple question you don't have
any information no you're adding more
things to my I'm I'm the one giving you
the situation would you let your son Mar
I'm saying if your son you don't have
any other information about the girl you
just hear this is a girl that has been
selling her body online she has had sex
online there are videos of her online
having sex with other men she's a and
your son says he wants to marry her
would you be happy with that decision it
is impossible to have uh your kids who
is dating somebody and have no
information at certain point you will
know I'm just giving you the information
I'm giving you this information it's not
about who would like that
so this is the thing she's she's trying
to she's trying to justify her reason
for for for
um become hard almost almost agree with
with the idea the reality is I'm not
agreeing with something I'm giving my
point of view but you are not listening
no you are not listening not
listening no because the point is the
point I'm trying to make is she's trying
to say oh if you had information on the
person no no that's not what I said if I
have a valuable reason why my kid want
want to marry that person cuz obviously
whoever the person is that my kid want
to marry I will ask either if it's a
corn star or not I will always ask why
that person you like
find but this is the point I'm trying to
this is difference this is another
difference between men and women a woman
would want to look for all the Fairy
Tale Fairy Land reasons why something
can work as a man I don't care what
reason my son has I'm going to look at
the possible detrimental effects that
his decision will have on his future
well yeah the carries the name as well
sorry one second one he's going to be
marrying someone that has videos of her
having sex online first of all that is
going to affect
whatever um what's it called whatever
um future aspirations he has in terms of
the social world because if he wants to
go into politics he wants to go into
anything like that anything that
involves him being a leader anything
that involves him interacting with other
people things like that will affect him
because his his enemies will always
bring up oh your well your wife has
videos they'll bring up videos like that
these are things if he's going to have
children my grandkids there's going to
be videos of their of her mom oh my God
having sex online so there is no reason
for me to think about oh but she might
be a good person or there might be a
good reason why no imagine having a
grandmother who's got porn with imagine
being like yeah my grandmother crazy I
actually find if my grandmother was
doing that I'm not going to throw her
away at the end of the day she stay my
grandma yes no but that's the point
because you wouldn't have a choice at
that point but what I'm telling you is
before that point you are talking about
okay after the fact as a kid no that's
what I'm talking about you you are
misunderstooding me cuz what you're
saying that I'm saying I'm not agreeing
with it meaning this you are not saying
what I'm saying you just said you just
said if you had a grammar that was doing
it you won't throw it away I'm telling
you that is because you don't have any
Choice she's your grandma she came
before you but what I'm saying is if you
have a son that is not yet married that
is you you will be solving a problem
that hasn't yet happened M but if you
are talking about your grandma that's
something that's I see in the same point
I still you don't because you're a woman
I understand I still I still have my
come on still going to stay on my on my
we're all the same on my decision I
think you guys are pretty much the same
it's just there are just very few
differences yeah I think that um I'm
going to stay on my decision because I'm
not a person who like you know how many
children have well recently Studies have
shown what there's more kids basically
committing suicide cuz they're getting
bullied at school cuz their mom's porn
corn stars and only don't worry they can
cry in the back of a Bugatti but they're
killing themselves is a whole so true
problem you know there's kids killing
themselves cuz they getting bullied at
school can you imagine how sad it is for
that kid to to live that life of going
to school having their peers or whatever
know that they people are watching their
mom oh my God
and what is your name please Dona Dona
can we not also talk about H why it's
happening if people react like this like
this sir right now who completely
attacked the imagin person that we're
talking about
King I personally like I'm saying I
would not take that situation like that
and start attacking people at the end of
the day it's a person majority of people
don't think like that if you have people
attacking people demonizing people and
going
around I have a question I have a
question if we live in a so Society
where we we can't discern who is good
and bad where does that leave us because
if we can no longer decide who is a
murderer who is a Grapist what we're
just going to let these people walk to
unfortunately there is there is a limit
there is a limit between the deciding
what is good and bad and bullying people
actually cuz obviously we have to decide
what is good and bad it has been like
the since the so only f is it good good
or
bad I mean other people do content that
is not sexual
so so only fans is it good or bad I
would say it depend on how you see it
cuz I know
people a murderer is that good or bad or
is it depends on how you see it a what a
murderer
a criminal obviously it's not good right
so how come you can decide what's good
or bad for for a murderer but you you
can't decide on something like only fans
because only fan is not a platform that
is designed to sell what we all talking
about now well that's where they're
making the money from it's from
vaginas it is she stuck on the word okay
let's not say only fans let's say
selling your body online because you're
trying to you're trying to dodge the
question by saying that well some people
don't do
is there's a difference between us
talking about only fun and sexual
content and I'm talking about only F
himself is not a bad platform it is a
platform that is most likely exclusive
where lot of people one different type
of exclusive content but if you're
talking
about something different the difference
is only your head because the reality is
we all know we speaking about we're
speaking about people that sell their
body online she used the word only fans
because that's the that is used
generally to describe it but we all know
we talking about women that sell their
body online so that's what she's saying
is selling your body online good or bad
it's not you're getting stuck on the
word only fans that's not what we're
talking about yeah not the corporation
the people who participate in selling
their body sexually explicitly online is
that good or
bad I personally do not agree with the
market but like said only fan himself is
another thing she she's the only fans
manager hold
on
must
AFF a quick question yeah you see how
you you see how you keep avoiding the
question yeah I'm not avoiding I give
the answer you just don't want to listen
there's a difference between me avoiding
a question and you not want to listen so
you just have to say I don't listen
that's the purpose that's the fact one
second you're too much in the middle
understanding you're too much in the
middle what you're attempting to do and
the question
you are not listening please this is not
your show you need to relax man like
relax I'm just I'm just talking all
right so look look here's what you're
doing you're mixing up what only fans
was created for as opposed to what it's
known for right now mixing up anything
maybe you're not understanding me but
I'm not mixing up I'm going to allow you
to finish speaking and then I'm going to
hope you're going to give me the same
respect afterwards to allow me to finish
speaking go on I'm finished to speak but
whenever you're going to mix up what I
said I'm going to you
know let him say what he needs to say
and then you can reute it however you
like but let him finish first okay
wonderful what you keep doing is you
keep trying to conflict the two things
we completely understand that only fans
wasn't created for porn stars corn Stars
we get it we understand that we know it
what it's known for right now and what
the topic is right now is about corn
stars using it for that reason we're
asking you a very direct question do you
think is good or bad and if you if you
want to still stay Melancholy about and
you want to stay right in the middle I'm
then going to ask you would you tell
your immediate loved ones to do it and
if you wouldn't tell them to do it then
your answer should be very clear it's
bad why are we flip-flopping do you
think it's bad yes or
no if you you know when you finish and
you look the video on YouTube You're
Going to see that I response the
question like said you are not listening
and I'm not going to repeat myself all
right so so so all of us here that have
tried to ask you the question multiple
times and you're going to say we're not
listening all right cool yeah she runs
only Fone still must
beit
crazy so from from my P perspective uh
what I see is I see a lot of women doing
things like only fans perhaps we should
use a different platform CU I feel like
you know maybe you are part of the pr
team for only fans maybe that's what's
going on here I'm joking I'm but I think
that uh you know when we are talking to
listen instead of being defensive you
know I I think you're sweetheart you're
talking about yourself right now you're
being defensive list here to discuss
something we're not here to the reality
is anything at all you're the one that
hasn't been listening the whole time
like this is this video is live and
there are people watching and I can I
can actually read the comments if you
want to see what they're saying in the
comments you I don't think you realize
how you're coming across but it's fine
when you get back home you can watch it
back and see whether you actually answer
the question what superat saying do you
do you think there's going to be a time
where only fans is just like outdated or
how do you guys see only fans it's going
to be AI fans next
yeah what would you mean like women
having their
what and put on like
an they do whatever you want fake girls
fake girls fake fake girls they started
recently as well hasn't they woman I
think it's going to be men who are
probably going to be hear
[__] I think it's going to be
men who are probably going to create
these AI women um and I mean cuz where
do you think the Privacy comes in are
there going to be legislations and laws
that will protect our photos them being
generated into AI characters no I don't
think they're going to be women's photos
turned into AI characters I think
they're just going to make AI characters
okay cuz then they don't have to worry
about any laws and regulations they can
just shortcut it which makes sense I
mean yeah it's crazy I mean the
technology is
just it's Advanced so quickly and I feel
like time is is getting quicker if that
Mak sense that the amount of Technology
that's come out and obviously something
like only fans what's that going to look
like now that AI has been introduced
into the world I
guess I don't know I think we're just
going to have to see when we get there
let's go yeah anyway my perspective at
the moment is that women who indulge in
this kind of promiscuous behavior um the
majority it seems like everyone here is
is
pretty normal grounded about the the
whole thing maybe some more than others
but the point is is that women encourage
each other to indulge in this kind of
behavior and and women we we preach this
whole body positivity thing to each
other do we agree or do we disagree that
women lie to each other all the time can
can I ask a question is is is height a
part of body body
positivity I mean women don't really get
judged on height and body positivity is
only a woman's thing oh oh that's that's
that's surprising to me so so that's a
double standard right of course okay
fair I just want I just wanted to know
at least someone was going to admit you
just Revelation just wanted to know man
[__] um do women lie to each other I
think women just lie in general
unfortunately women are worse than girls
yeah unfortunately don't they lie at
least like 70 times a day about the
smallest stuff yeah it's a bit crazy I'm
not going to lie you two look really
Iz experiences hey you know do you know
is saying oh you guys do you know what
it is yeah I have I have a I have a very
big problem with his body POS body
positivity thing yeah because the man
them that are high challenged aren't
getting no love what you mean by high
challenged explain what a high challeng
challeng under six foot under six foot
so listen if you if you need to step
into the kitchen and tipto or anything
that's called a height challenge yeah
that's mad I'm not going to it's called
it's called a height challenge you get
me okay so I just I just want to know
because anytime like I'm on clubhouse
regularly anytime that we have these
conversations it seems like it's like oh
my gosh don't don't mention this
person's weight and don't mention this
and that and then like the man being
hype shamed and told that I don't want
to date you because you're hype but why
is that not part of the body body
positivity like yeah why going for the
short man
then like what what can we can we show
some love to them and them that are
heighty challenged listen it's all about
the Personality yeah money and Heights
don't mean a thing so you don't care
about height that's a lie um I don't
look how long it took her to think about
that did a long pause in it hey man you
got no chance I'm not going to lie can I
reply did you ask me a question let me
[__] reply then oh [__] listen um for
me I think everybody reacts differently
I'm a kind of person I look at
personality energy there's other things
that can pull me into be attracted to
somebody right I've I've dated somebody
that's the same height as me do you I
mean I've not been like oh you're a
[__] no I don't want to well you're
not with are you you're not together but
that that isn't the reason why I'm not
with them though how many relation that
shed to be like let me put the
physicality into into a potential so why
did you mention that he was the same
height instead
of why you bring up
his why did she bring up his hat why did
she bring up his hat what's going on she
you have to bring up his hat because
we're talking about height so stop it no
but why is he the same height as you why
is he not shorter why couldn't you tell
us about a shorter guy that you had a
relationship with cuz it just hasn't
happen but when it does I'll come back
and let
you it makes sense oh body positivity
yeah oh you got a very is there is is
there a reason why you choose not to
date short men H did you not just listen
to my answer you said the listen to my
you said was the same height not sure no
no no before that did you not listen to
what I just said I said I get attracted
by someone's energy personality it's not
the physicality or the money that
attracts me something so have you been
with a but then I don't tolerate
[__] at the same have you have you
been with a guy that's shorter than you
I have been oh [__] I'm quite tall
though I'm about 57 5'8 in between but
have you been with the guy that you have
cap
interesting
what not [__] like
just initially you only mentioned a guy
who was
the um did you have to lift him
up you have to rock do you have to rock
him to sleep tuck him in who said that I
slept with him what do you mean by been
I'm I'm talking about going on a date
not sleeping with somebody was he oh
just the date yeah I'm talking about
talking about sleeping with somebody she
used him for his money oh that's
crazy obviously fair enough what do
people use you for
[Music]
then [__] is it your Al or your what I
personally stand up let me see how tall
you are I personally I'm 6ot are you I
personally when you when you said you've
dated someone that is um shorter than
you it doesn't count if you if you
didn't sleep with them really actually
really doesn't count it doesn't count if
you didn't sleep with them because we're
talking about people you're attracted to
so if you if you didn't get to the point
of sleeping with him but that's what
they were talking about their
reaction N I think I think we mean that
the guys that actually make it to the
finish line so if he didn't make it to
the Finish Line then he there no need
for me to talk then okay sorry hey if he
stood up and he was under six foot would
you be
upset no oh fair enough why upset I
thought I thought you would have sh
minute no I wouldn't I'm just teasing
listen I'm not going to be malice and be
a Dicker like I'm a respectful person
but I will make you laugh and educate
you at the same time just myself that's
an unfortunate endeav I have been in a
relationship with a person that is
shorter than me well just one par just
one just one what does that mean one
person just one relationship or multiple
as I'm talking about the person that was
short yeah just one person then how many
short how many short guys you been out
with one person one short guy one short
guy okay that makes sense how many
relationship you
had is the personal question to
ask my first relationship what you mean
it's a personal is it so bad to ask you
how many relationship is that a bad
thing now no it ain't
what don't worry don't worry we we got
this was it just one short guy one short
relationship he the first person I dated
as I was in a relationship with
okay so you dated the height challenge
that
we didn't as we we were in a reli ship
how did it go how short was he I love
how you guys just made he was he was
because no one's going to call us out
for he shaming like it doesn't happen
this is a new thing he was 56 I believe
and I'm 511 oh wow wow yeah M did you
have to pick him up to hug him don't be
mean don't be mean don't be mean you
know what it is do you know what it is
yeah do you know what it is yeah don't
be mean I find it absolutely it's a bit
awkward though especially for
at that like listen if this clip goes
out and I was weight shaming someone I'd
be cancelled yeah you see the for some
reason they keep going under the radar
pun intended you get it I'm just like
what we doing I'm just but the thing is
men hold let's flip the coin here do you
find it weird if a woman's taller than
you no no oh exactly so why is why is
that though why is that between men and
women we have like but would you date an
overweight woman oh there we go there we
go
so hold on hold on hold on hold on
overweight overweight and obese are two
different things yeah are you talking
overweight or
obese two different things obese obese
is extremely overweight for your height
BMI whatever it is even though everyone
says BMI a few extra pounds like a bit
chubs obese is extremely overweight okay
so you're not just little bit
chubby that's 300 bit of cing right here
no no that's none of that it's it's
excessive being overweight is just your
your BMI could be like X and then you're
you're literally like so answer the
question someone as big as lizo would
you date
them do you have a motive first
respectfully no I respect the confidence
but respectfully what confidence why
what what is it that you respect the
confidence is it like yo if you if you
the confidence to be that unhealthy
encourage other do they want to bang or
date that's that's a now listen if you
are this person and you are shaped like
this do your thing if you're confident
in it do your thing think shaped like
that I think I think there's a bad food
to mouth ratio but there's not much that
I can really say like in regards to it
you get like no like no one like no one
is big bon no one is Big Bones we've
seen the skeletons no one is Big Bones
so we do
understand that a lot no no no what
you're about to do is you're about to
say oh there's some qualif complications
and blah blah blah no you're talking
about anomalies the vast majority of
people that are I love how you know me
already I know because you about to you
know me already the vast majority of
people that are overweight from what I
understand it's just a bad food to my
ratio and we completely understand that
if you're happy within yourself do your
thing that's got no problem with me but
you can't I want to stop you right there
I want to stop you right there so your
your philosophy is that if you're happy
in yourself um then then that's okay so
would you then encourage someone who say
uh has an un healthy drug addiction oh
but they're happy in themselves so you
do you no uh it's not my life if you're
happy within yourself I'm not going to
give you any advice in regards what
about if it's a friend or someone you
love if it's my friend that's someone I
care about then of course I'm going to
take an actual care okay I have a
question if the man were overweight I
would tell them man them my bro your
belly kind of hanging over the belt your
thing is moving kind of mad like my bro
like I'm going to I'm going to par you
don't get it twisted but we're then
going to go to the gym together and
we're going to bang it out and we're
going to make sure you get to where you
need to be we're not just going to leave
you and be like oh my gosh body
positivity you look so good surprise me
this doesn't surprise me that a male is
giving this answer so I want to hear
what the girls think simple question
would you tell your girlfriend if she's
fat I would tell people I'm I'm real so
whatever's going on that doesn't benefit
them I will say it to them but each
person is different it depends on how
you deliver things but yeah I'm real if
there's something going on if you're
drinking too much if you're doing this
too much if you're eating too much
you're not looking good too much I will
say it for their own not from my own but
it depends on how you deliver it that's
the problem people I call c i call same
same and the reason why I call C is
because you actually didn't answer the
question you you said a whole lot of
different things she asked she asked a
straight question yes would you tell
your friends if they fat you didn't have
to start saying well there's a way she
did the whole story that you didn't
answer the question I'm giving a
relevant story but yes yeah you tell
your friend if that they tell me all the
time if I look ugly I'll tell them if
they look a bit you know your friends
tell you when they think you look ugly
yeah you sound like You' got good
friends I think they are very good
friends shout
out I will
not wait wait wait wait let her speak
let her land I was actually initially
finished since we need just to give a a
short answer but if I need to elaborate
if a person as if my friend is fat I
will not tell her that you are fat why
will I say that so you're going to make
if if she is unhealthy and I know that
she have a health condition dies will
related to her weight I'm going to make
my way to let her know that we need
together to work on it but just saying
you're fat that's not okay well that's
what I was saying I never said it and I
I will never say it I get this I get
this this is the woman's mentality and
I'm a woman so I that's my mentality
that's not about a
woman thought of telling another woman
we fat yeah it's
hurtful okay I wouldn't put it like that
either right but okay let me rephrase it
in a feminine way you have a girlfriend
right you've been friends for a long
long time 5 to 10 years okay that means
nothing to me I still get rid of people
just follow me for a second just follow
my story so you're good friends you got
great relationship forget the time she's
your
girl she's gaining she is gaining tub
right she's got a bit of a double chin
going perhaps when she wears a crop top
half of it hanging out a bit you know
she's starting to get the whole
arm Wings [__] going on are you letting
her know hey I've noticed that you're
gaining a bit of weight yeah is
everything okay is there something we
can do here
or let's say let's add another context
in here she's all over Instagram and
everything say she has a Tik Tok account
right and she's one of these body
positivity Advocates and she has loads
of fans telling her you go girl body
positivity right so she's continuingly
gaining weight eating food yes that's
how people gain weight she's continuing
to gain weight because she's being body
positive and she wants to stop the idea
of fat shaming uh what are you
doing I think as a good friend you
obviously need to be like look like
friend to friend I think you know you've
you know like respectfully and like not
you can't just be like you're fat like
respectfully you you you can I'm sure if
I started getting fat P would say to me
girl you're getting fat but I don't
think most girls would put it like
yeah people get like people sensitive
especially women they're quite sensitive
obviously tell them in a way that you
know respectfully look I think you
know you need to add slow down whatever
you may say but then at the same time
you give them what you give them but if
they're deciding to listen to other
people and do this whole thing that's
that's up to them I have a question is
it
actually cuz I'm kind of torn now I know
it's it's feminine nature to put it
nicely right but actually thinking about
it right if I'm this girl and I'm
getting fat and I I see no problem with
it I'm like I feel good I'm body
positive and my friend comes to me she
says look I've noticed you're gaining
weight is there anything we can do to
help that's not really going to prompt
me to change actually if my friend came
to me and went you are fat what is going
on that's going to prompt me to change
so actually as women are we actually
harming each other with this feminine
neness would it not be better for us if
we were more harsh like how men are with
each other like bro you're getting fat
we're going to the gym would it not be
actually better for us if we were able
to speak to each other the same way that
men speak to each other can I just say
yeah you look would never survive a Call
of Duty Lobby in
2012 yeah you would never survive it it
doesn't make any sense I'm you survive
I'm good yeah you're you're a buit
different still we understand that man
it's a little bit different but listen
when when you go into these lobbies and
you're being called Everything Under the
Sun listen you don't even know I'm black
but I'm being called the NW before I've
even said anything how did you know how
how did you not what I'm trying to say
is I feel like if I'm coddling you and
I'm like oh my gosh that's not going to
help though it's not going to help
you're getting slightly chubby oh my
goodness can we um can we sort it out
that's not going to motivate you to do
anything but listen people can be harsh
you can be nice in the beginning you can
explain things cuz you never know the
reasoning to why is gaining weight and
I'm talking from experience I've had th
thyroid problems which affect my
hormones which then can affect our
weight right so somebody might not know
what's going on but they are putting on
weight and they are unconsciously a bit
scared maybe to talk about their health
problems or whatever it is but then when
you talk about a situation with
someone's deliberately doing the same
behavioral pattern talking uh eating the
same crappy foods and carrying on with
that behavior and you don't address it
you're a [__] friend in my opinion if
you deliver it in a certain way to
understand what the root caus is and you
understand the root causes them just
eating crap then maybe have a different
approach but again this is what I meant
the circumstance can be different I see
what you're saying but I I want to argue
the point that at the end of the day um
how much does the root cause really
matter here's the thing let me because
you want to fix so what's the reason for
you telling them their fact they want
you want them to improve let let me let
me put more perspective on this the the
reality what I've noticed is women
actually secretly hate each other women
are not real friends to each other and
that's why they always have to pretend
the reason why I don't have a problem
with my bro telling me [__] as blunt as
possible is because I know he's my bro
and I know he has my best interest at
heart so no matter how he says it I'm
not going to take it the wrong way the
reason why you women always take things
the wrong way is because secretly you
don't know if that woman is truly your
friend you guys hang out to people that
are not you're not real friends you hate
each other secretly so whenever a woman
comes to you and say something you take
it sideways like oh that [__] why would
she even say that to me because you're
not real friends if me and my bro have
been through all sorts of [__] together
maybe we were on the streets together we
came up together there's nothing he
wants to say to me there's no how he's
going to deliver it I'm going to take it
the wrong way unless of course we are
now at a point where he's done something
I don't consider him my friend anymore
all listen if I'm getting fat and the
man can't tell me I'm getting fat not my
R blood you shouldn't have around you
yeah you me I'm even mad if I'm getting
fat and my stomach hanging over the belt
a little bit my my chin getting a bit
doubly chess get getting a bit rasty and
that and you don't tell me as the mandm
and we're going out and we're enjoying
ourselves and we're doing the madness
and you can see people looking at me we
you're a bad friend like what we doing I
want to hear I want to hear the other
side uh you said that you wouldn't say
anything what what's your reasons for
that as my point of view obviously was
different like I said uh I'm not going
to say to a person you fat and uh yeah
but in the context that you mentioned
that if is my friend she was healthy
before and now she's gaining weight my
Approach would be obviously to ask if uh
there's anything if
she as what is happening of her gaining
weight is she feeling comfortable
gaining weight or is she obviously
actually stressed so for you is it about
the subjective emotion the person's
feeling so if they're gaining weight but
they're still happy in their own skin
you're okay with that as like said if
there is any health issue related to
that I don't think that because for me
the point with as the the the whole
thing with body positivity for me I'm
not personally too focused on the body I
think it's more about the health and
what I mean health is your mental health
and uh obviously your health himself in
your mental health but doesn't working
out improve the mental health no
wor but forget that
being overweight brings health problems
so it doesn't matter if the health
problems are the reason that the weight
is coming the weight will inevitably
bring problems with it so my question to
you is you talked you talked about being
as a overweight if you're overweight it
says in the word overweight it obviously
bring problems of um health problem so
are you going to present that to your
friend even if they say I am perfectly
happy in my own skin
I feel great like said whenever there is
a health issue involved I'm going to
speak about it cuz health is more
important than
looks so you wait until they're already
dying before
you this is not what I said one one more
time again you're trying to you know Mis
understand what you
want what I said no I actually I
actually purposely made it exaggerated
it but the point stands the point is
what you're saying is you're going to
wait until there's a health issue before
you bring it up but the reality is what
you should do as a friend is to bring it
up because the reality is some people
don't even know yeah what's going on
when it could be when something could be
going wrong with them but if you bring
it up then they could look like okay
maybe I should go to the hospital and
actually check myself up but you
wouldn't bring it up until maybe they
they they've probably fainted one day
and then they go to the hospital and
they get once again you are
misunderstanding you me something
there's nothing that I said that I can
relate that I said unfortunately cuz
heal is not is not only getting
physically uh as that that you're sick
is not that you get um how do you say it
in English you don't have to be
physically sick to be sick your mental
health can already be deterior for you
to be sick look I'm never trying if the
person is not happy being
F and the person is
not I'm not even trying to be funny but
I just find it funny how you keep saying
I am misunderstanding where you're when
you're the one that doesn't really
understand English it's just very funny
because I understand exactly there a
difference between not understanding
English and and me not maybe putting in
the way what I want to say because what
I want to say I Mis anything I I to say
analog what you are saying is absolutely
not what I said the question I I will
not wait for my friend to be able to be
on a way to die before I'm question was
overweight over over
a woman that's taller or more overweight
let's look at both aspects okay tell me
explain overweight yes obese No taller
yes really doesn't matter to me depends
I'm 62 out and I'm dep it depends on how
overweight she is think about other men
though let's talk about a general
perspective here if she's if she's a bit
on a thick side then little tickers you
get little bounce like the BMI might say
differently but you know in right it
doesn't put you off and a bit of where
it doesn't put you off no no no no it
just depends on how much weight cuz does
it depend on the face as well she has to
be I'm not going to lie she has to be
pretty okay so there's standards here
now CU there are some pretty
fact you got to say overweight and we
going to be politically correct no you
can say fast say no we can't say over
just say
overweight chck with C faces yeah there
is there is there is CH get me they can
always that might be TOs
they can always go turkey and so and get
a BB easy things hey but let me ask a
quick question yeah or just or just go I
I I genuinely I don't even feel like
this what I'm saying I don't even feel
like this is a bit of a Madness yeah let
me ask you a question yeah let's say for
example you was G can you hear me let's
say for example you g out with your
Breen yeah it's your Breen's birthday
yeah she's bought this one dress that is
not befitting of her figure at all yeah
she's put the dress on the dress looks
mad but it's her birthday dress it's her
dream dress she knows wagan oh [__] this
is how I want to look she's she she
fitted the hair but the hair is not
hairing do you get me certain things are
lifting do you get what I'm saying maybe
the glue was not too gluey you see what
I'm saying that that type of thing in
general it's your Brethren's birthday
would you look at her in that situation
let her go out and at least and let her
go out would you at least be honest and
be like yo babes look you might want to
change the dress I know this is your
birthday dress X Y said you might want
to change it because it's not flattering
or if the wig might be lifting or the
hair might be hair
the extension extension all right bait
us out the
[__] let her answer let her answer as
much room as possible would would you
tell her clicking my hair Essentials you
need to rephrase again properly what you
trying to say cuz you have mentioned a
lot of things her hair your friend
essentially looks awful she looks
terrible youc ways you can you can see
she just she doesn't look good right but
she thinks she does are you letting her
go out looking like that or are you
telling her love you to pieces but you
look like
[__] well if her outfit is looking all
over the place and her wig is Lifting
and her eyelashes glue wherever
obviously I'm going to tell that because
this is not how you put on the wig this
is not how you put the eyelashes but if
everything is looking good but it's just
a question of a person not finding it
good I don't know what to say no fair
enough fair enough okay right we we're I
I don't know if I if I think that this
is truthful based on your other answer
however you're you're entitled to your
opinion so we we'll we'll leave it at
that well so we've established that
women lie to each other okay um we won't
get into why because that's a whole
other long conversation more to women or
to men
men uh I think we just Li in general I
think we we we have adapted in such a
way that we're extremely manipulative um
and it's a survival tactic and I think
in today's day and age it has been
overinflated to the point where women
get away with lying about things that we
don't even need to lie about anymore
okay um so a question I have about
female nature um is can women make good
decisions can go into so many let me
give more context a bit more context let
give more context cuz people women go
into deep of course we we overthink
everything what can I do I've been
designed like this can women make good
decisions but who makes a better
decision a man or a woman well men
better at making decisions we lead with
emotions men lead with logic so you can
understand which better
situation so you're saying I'm saying
logic you're saying men make better
decisions yeah in general General it's
man I think it really depends I'll be
honest with you on um so women haven't
been put in certain positions to be able
to have enough data for us to be like oh
you make considerably better decisions
than men or worse they just haven't been
put in those positions before have they
not been put in those positions oh for
multitude of reasons um such as mandm
being mandm stay in A Woman's Place
prime
example hang on a minute hang on a
minute wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait so you're suggesting that the
reason that women aren't in significant
positions of power I'm not suggesting
that at all so are you s you just said
that because of to quote yourself I said
I said the I said the reason why both of
them are is it's POS I don't know which
you said that women don't have enough
data available there's four girls here
fine the question I'm trying to ask is
are you I I correct me if I'm wrong but
it sounds like you're kind of going
along the lines of patriarchy is that
what you're saying no no no so long
story short long story short what I'm
saying isely we don't have enough data
on both ends of both people doing the
same amount of things to be able to be
like this person does better than the
other so for example if we had as many
dictators as we did male dictators as we
did women we can therefore be like all
right cool let's come in the middle and
we can say this person did better as
opposed to they killed more people wait
not because they killed more people but
because it could be because they did
better no no it could be because they
they just did better for their Community
it could literally just be that survival
exactly it could be you know you you you
put something in place for your
community in order for them to gain so
much benefits like seven to 70 years
down the line like let's say for example
um we look at War if we had as many
women in war as we did men perpetuating
the war and we brought it together we
could be like all right cool well we can
genuinely tell that this person is
better
the hold up hold I'm going to fact check
you right there uh women have actually
waged more in history uh women are more
likely to wage war than men okay and
that's based off of the data set that we
have that is men typically tend to be in
positions of power more even with men in
power more women are still more likely
to wage war so what I would suggest is
that we look at the situation we're in
which is that men are in significant
positions of power more than women why
is that
is it because of this idea of a
patriarchy and that men have oppressed
women and that and that women have just
been told to keep in their place and
that's why men in positions of power or
is it that men are just better at it but
we again we can't make that judgment
because we haven't had enough of a
sample sample to be able to say that
again how long I give you an example I
give you an example look look we've had
maybe a 100 men I'm just throwing
numbers out there we've had maybe a 100
men being mad amount of positions of
power and run countries amazingly we've
only had a select number of women be in
a position of power and everything that
they do might
bealy in a normal society anyway and
that's what that's why I'm saying it's
difficult America right now that are
telling women you might be drawn to go
to
war what obviously I I don't I don't
want to get into that I believe in equal
rights cuz you fought for it but I'm not
trying to get equal rights I'm sorry wom
should not be going to war first
you want so we're going to be
equal we need to we need to say conflict
in in in in general you have to
understand this the way I'm seeing it
I'm seeing in just just the graphical
graphical situation in general of course
men have been in multiple positions of
power which
means one second one second anyone that
messes up the stat is not going to be
the same you see what I'm saying if a
100 men do do a Madness and 10% of the
man didn't [__] up as opposed to 10 10
women being in the same situation and
one woman [__] up or two women
[__] up bro that's 20% as opposed to
10% we we just don't have
enough I said I said I said 100 I said
100 men 10% getting it wrong that's 10
men if we have 10 women and 20% getting
it wrong that's two women the percentage
is likely to be higher so what I'm
trying to what I'm trying to say to you
is the reason why I don't want to say
one side or the other it's just we just
don't have enough data to be able to say
it I believe that there's been women in
power that have done AB abolutely
amazing and we could see other women
that are in situations that do amazing
things have majority of FS to challenge
to challenge toen to challenge you on
that point the problem with your point
is that you're looking at it from a very
recent point of view true so how many
years do you think human beings have
existed on on the face of the
earth a lot right like probably hundreds
of thousands of years so for most part
for most part of that time it's only
like very it's only a very small
percentage of that time that we've seen
modern society right mhm and wom so most
of the way human beings behave today is
not based on this our new way of living
in our new technological Society is
actually based on thousands of years of
evolution MH now based off of that men
and women operate not because of
Oppression or because women need to stay
in their Lan it's because of this is how
human being have actually had to be to
survive so if there are not women in
power it's not because men don't want
women to be in power it's because women
have not been able to be in power oh I
never said the men didn't want them to
be in power I'm just saying we just
don't
have no meaning men have been the more
competent ones to be in power it's but
we take everything over so of course
we're going to be exactly but isn't that
just that is why we are the ones that
are more likely to be power because we
bro being able to take something over
doesn't mean you're good to to to lead
it that's why I'm saying the problem
have enough problem how can you defend
how can you lead something you can't
defend that's
true so if you have an ideology the only
way for your ideology to fly is if
you're willing to stand with your life
and defend it the problem with today's
society is women claim they have all
this right way of thinking and this
ideologies but they cannot even defend
themselves they still need men to defend
their
ideologies you see what just happened
there a brother gave me some some
knowledge and I conceded on the point
because I just recognize that he was
correct you get it I feel like we need
to have some more accountability
yeah no he's right he's right fair
enough Romeo can women make good
decisions can women make good decisions
it depends on the type of woman um what
does it depend on um her intelligence
and what she's what she's got to to give
you know um
all women are different as you can see
there's we got these only fans women
we've got in general oh in
general that wasn't a question you asked
me
though change a
littleit okay who makes better decisions
men or women there we go there we go um
men overall right so I'm going to ask
the original question again minus the
feminine context can women gen as a
majority the female species do we make
good
decisions you can do at times yeah not
the majority of the time do we make good
decisions no why not no why why do you
say no um I think there's a and again I
feel like women kind of play I feel like
women kind of play into this you you you
guys are a bit in a bubble mhm it's like
your your like your friends your give
you terrible advice if I'm being honest
your will give you terrible advice
weren't you the same guy talking about
accountability a couple of minutes ago
yeah exactly so what's the advice got to
do with it if you're accountable for
your own actions but women aren't
accountable for their own actions and
that's the point fair enough there we go
so what I'm trying to say is women
aren't necessarily accountable for a lot
of the things that they do but not only
that women like their Brethren give
terrible advice so instead of like for
example if there's a massive breakup or
something go heal go relax go chill no
it's City girl time thr that ass in a
circle do your Madness go go do whatever
you want to do and it's like that's not
good advice that's not how you deal with
your emotions and do you know what it is
you see when you flip these situations
and it's
like both parties start partaking in a
terrible
Behavior women don't like it and it's
like why why you don't give her terrible
advice okay I want to I want to you seem
like you have some thoughts no no no no
no it's a fair point where he just said
but you're saying that oh when a girl
I'm going to use what you said about the
whole breakup thing when a girl breaks
up with a boyfriend whever she's going
around going out enjoying time with the
girls but what what are you men doing
you guys aren't at home G can't compare
each other to men cuz we want to be
apparently Superior we're going to the
gym and playing Call of Duty that's what
we
do that's that's what you do but that is
not what a large major t do you are out
there trying to clap cheeks straight
away the vast majority of Men Don't Clap
cheeks so what are you talking about
what's going on about clapping cheeks
you're theu that word I
know bit of manness here but we're
moving it we're but the vast majority
been cap cheeks so what do we do from
there we trying to you we're still going
out and stuff you think that that girls
just go out cuz we're trying to trying
[Music]
to let her finish lot of you when a girl
breaks up She Goes out with her with her
friends yeah not all of them but
majority of them might do that but a lot
of them a lot of the times not because
they're trying to get down and day a lot
of times they just want to just enjoy
with their girls and and we're emotional
so we just want to we just want to
distract ourselves okay I have a
question wait I have a question um so if
it's if it's just about you know being
with your girls and being around your
girls wouldn't have they told you that
you were the [__] boyfriend no why do
you need to do that at the club yeah
yeah no you don't you don't have to do
that at the club I can like I'm I'm for
for speaking for myself I wouldn't do
that M but the club is a I feel like a
club is a place that just very
distracting Girls natur Just Want to be
fully distracted from from from their is
that healthy no it's not so why do we
encourage each other to do it my friends
don't encourage me to do it so last oh
you're clearly an
anomaly well maybe
but Danica welcome back hi um I want to
know do women make good decisions no why
not definitely not especially like you
were saying earlier on uh women tend to
especially in a group I don't trust
anybody that has more than four or five
friends and I'm talking at the age of 30
and everybody at different ages at
different stages of their lives will
understand things differently when
you're young you might not really
realize that somebody's talking [__] to
you and encouraging you in a negative
way even though they've got hate for you
and they around you just for jealousy
sake because they want to be around the
same people that you know whatever it is
interior motive but when you reach a
certain age and you're doing the same
stupidity of letting other people cuz
everybody knows deep down when you've
made a mistake everybody deep down
unconsciously or they feel theyve got it
in the pit of the summer when they know
they're doing something wrong and then
other people validating that PA one
second this I just have something to say
about this so you said everyone knows
when we're doing something wrong or
conscious normality yes actually in the
modern day a study came out in 2023 um
it was a study on uh casual sex
encounters between men and women and it
was a longitudinal study that looks at
sexual action regret and sexual inaction
regret so we know that men typically
regret passing up sexual offers they
they regret turning down casual sex
whereas women tend to regret more having
casual sex so when we had casual sex we
tend to regret it so this study
essentially aimed to look at
you know who how do we learn from regret
so if we have the emotion of regret
surely it should be there to tell us
we've done something wrong and we should
probably change our Behavior what this
study found is that regret seems to be
working pretty well in in men when men
hand in hand with denial unfortunately
when men regret have sexual regret so
they they've passed up an offer of
casual sex um they they changed their
behavior to make sure they don't fill
that again actually what this study
found is that when women have
experienced regret after a casual sexual
encounter it has had zero effect on the
number of their sexual partners and they
still indulge in the same behavior so
women are feeling regret but something
has gone seriously wrong in our
psychology because we can no longer
learn from the feeling of regret I can
add that to that as well actually
majority majority let's say 80 to 85% of
women that have been sexually abused
tend to become hypersexualized mhm right
so the behaviors then become they want
to have more sex which is a very strange
thing to actually when you think about
it from an outside perspective but
majority more than majority of women
that have been sexually abused tend to
be become hypers sexually
hypersexualized and have more sex I want
to have more sex now where the psyche
why that's like a more more of a depth
kind of conversation to go into but I
think that's what I'm seeing more in
today's society as okay sexual abuse can
be different things and by the way I
don't like the fact that women over I
feel like sexual abuse has been changed
as a concept throughout the years by the
way I agree but before we go into that
topic AB same question do women
generally majority of women no specifics
as a group do we tend to make good
decisions um I personally I don't I
don't have any thought about that but if
we have to carry on as if I have to
carry on on a logic that of the first
question you asked if between men and
women who make the best better decisions
so I would
say yeah I don't I don't have any
specific things to say if there is not
any more context um in so women as a
group in general would you say they tend
to make good decisions or they tend to
make bad decisions this is not to deny
the fact that there are exceptions but
the majority of women do we make good
decisions or bad decisions like I said I
don't have any ideas on that cuz I I
didn't read anything about this and uh I
don't okay so let's talk about let's
talk about anecdotes uh you know
statistics and facts and science aside
let's just talk about what we what we
see in society so if women are good at
at making decisions generally let's go
with that consensus why is it that
pretty much every girl I've ever spoke
to has had some kind of toxic
ex mhm have any of you on the sofa had a
toxic
ex I've had toxic situations but I I
don't really want to go into it yeah
yeah I would say have you had a toxic ex
relationship have you had an encounter
with a man who you would class as
toxic I I would say that most of men are
toxic but uh if we have to see on that
way what the hell wait you said that you
just came at the right time at the right
time what did you just say let her
elaborate okay let her finish let her
land um I mean I will ask as well if a
man didn't had the toxic ex which is the
case so no but he just said he just said
something M just said that all most men
are toxic yeah yeah can you can you Su
can can you um extend on that please I
don't know how to stend in more cuz this
Ang but uh it's for me personally I
believe that um there's more toxicity in
general as well it's not even about have
you met 51% of the men on the
world no how many Rel how how can you
make that judgment then how many men
have you been with we're talking about
we're not talking about we're not
talking about every man we so Sur we
should have make absolute are toxic is
that what you're saying as nobody has
said that I'm not sure no but you made
an absolute statement which is most men
are said she said she said she thinks
the majority which means more than 51%
most so can you substantiate that thanks
for having by guys so can you
substantiate that I what so what what do
you what do you when you say that the
majority of men are toxic can you tell
us what you mean by
toxic what what what constitutes a toxic
man PA for the first date oh
gosh her finish
finish Jesus so the context of your
statement the majority of men are toxic
what is toxic to you in in in that
statement as well in that statement I
will go more for the the mentality of
men in the society when it comes to
dating so what does that look
like so I don't really have an idea uh
because like say again I don't have any
study read or I don't know it's not
something no that's okay in your in your
personal opinion
but
um
yeah what men are you dating so can we
agree some men or toxic then scen as you
can't substanti what you're talking
about um I don't know how to put it in a
way but um I think that's in general men
have a
very toxic point of view when it comes
to they but what does what is the toxic
that you're referring to what is it
that's toxic
you have to explain when you say have
you met 3. billion go into dep because
we're not here just to like listen to
brief things we need to understand your
opinion so bro she wants a man that
earns 4K a month bro or more than 4K
more more than that man yeah more than
4K 4.5 yeah have you have you met 3.6
billion men in the world let her Define
toxic first so just in the statement
that you said what is toxic to you
forget studies statistics forget
definitions it's 20 23 apparently a man
can be a woman and a woman can be a man
oh that's crazy exactly
toxic well I'm not going to go into this
detail right now cuz like said this is
not a topic that I personally I go for
in my daily basis but from my point of
view um yeah what's toxic for women what
do you see is toxic within women by the
way I'm asking the guys here what what
ju what cuz obviously it's different for
men and women like we might see
something toxic within a man's beh
behavior that might be different but
obviously men might see different things
what's like a red flag or something
toxic Behavior wise whatever within a
woman you first bro I I can say I can
say one one is saying things like most
men are toxic that that is that is
toxicx because for you to say most men
are toxic in relationship that means
you've mostly been with toxic men but
that doesn't really prove that men are
toxic that just proves that the men you
date are toxic and for you to date
mostly toxic men that means you yourself
are
toxic that's
how wow I also want to know the the same
question so was the answer for me or was
it a general cuz I need to clarify that
I was asking the man for you for you
what's toxic to you Mr King was the
answer for me or was it a general no no
no yeah I was speaking about you cuz you
said most men are toxic so I'm saying
for you to say that that just that
doesn't mean that that's true it just
means that you date mostly toxic men and
if you date mostly toxic men that means
that that's what you attract and if
that's what you attract that means
you're most likely toxic as well so it's
just the thing is it's very easy for
women to point fingers forgetting that
the remaining four fingers that they
pointing are facing themselves so if you
if you date mostly toxic people like
it's it's okay for a woman to date to
have to make a mistake you meet one
toxic guy you meet two toxic guys but if
you have this view that most men are
toxic that just means that most of the
guys you've dated are toxic and that
only points to the fact that you toxic
as well I'm trying to go at you I'm just
analyzing what you said yeah but your
analyzing doesn't stand for me cuz uh
first of all you don't even know if I'm
dating or if I had dated so it doesn't
no but you made you made a statement
that most men are toxic in dating so you
cannot make that statement if you don't
date because that you're just talking
about what you don't know about no you
can't see I can so you know more than
51% of men no so let me get this
straight you're you're saying you're
saying a aside from your personal
experience from General observation of
the population you've come to the
conclusion that men when dating are
toxic so let's go with that for a second
let's take the word toxic out of it what
are some problems with men today that
would lead you to believe that the
majority of men are toxic give us a
toxic trait man let's take the word
toxic out of it because we've already
established that we can't seem to get a
definition for that so what are some
problems with men today that you have
seen that has led you to that statement
yeah most of young people in general
people don't want to commit so that's
one toxic trait commit or commit to you
no no I'm not talking about me I'm
talking about General commit commit
pushed away you quantify Commitment if
it's not towards yourself what are you
looking at your brethren and saying yo
how many Comm want commit because there
something to commit to that's the
problem sounds like a you problem man
sounds like problem are we not agreeing
that this uh this generation have
commitment issues to you going to deny
it no no no no no again I feel like
you're talking about a personal
situation they may have a I'm not
talking about personal situation you the
one you are the one forcing thinking
that I'm talking you just said this
generation has a commitment issue and
I'm saying I'm I'm making general
statement I'm not talking about me I
didn't say I okay you see the problem
with making General and V sweeping
statements you're saying that more than
51% of X do x y and Zed you don't have
have that data let's stop making
absolute statements because we cannot
fact it is fact that's in this
generation it's a fact people don't want
to commit it's a fact it is a fact in
where the Western world or the world in
the whole world especially in the
Western World prove that right now for
me me you can just go on a Google just
pull up your tone and go on
gole you you guys hold on hold hold on
again again you guys are mixing up she
just said the world you don't have the
stat for that because there's no stat
that the world is specifically the
Western world because we on the western
you mean the world is specifically the
Western World I ask you about the world
I didn't ask you about a certain
demographic of the
worlding up everything even with the
specific demographic of the Western
World you have no stats or statistics to
back up what you just said you're making
stat about the Western I'm sure all I'm
saying is when it comes to us actually
speaking about things can we just speak
in less absolutes stop saying most and
this and that because is not 51% you
don't know the 51% of men X1 you don't
know any of these things okay so let's
take let's take General generalizations
out of this thank you let's let's talk
about personal experience so but
actually no I disagree with that um you
can't actually like for the first time
I'm going to back you up we can actually
the no no because no the reality we're
start seeing R we can actually we can
actually make General statements the
only issue is if you make a general
statement that is factually incorrect
like we can make General statements
about the world what we see but when you
say stuff like most men are toxic that
is a factually incorrect statement facts
so there's nothing wrong in making a
general statement for instance you can
say most men like to sleep around if
given the opportunity that is generally
factual so there's nothing wrong with
that statement but when you say
something like most men are toxic then
you have to come with your facts and
back it up you can't just say something
like that and then when you're asked to
explain how then you say no I can't get
into that no then don't make the
statement thank you so one of the issues
that you you pointed out was uh
commitment um and you said that it
applies both to to men and women but
what I wanted to know was because of
your statement about men specifically uh
being more toxic in in dating than women
what are some big issues this is not
what I said I didn't say men are more
tox toxic than women I'm saying that i'
said men are the as men are toxic this
is
whatx compar said are toxic she do
compare to women but we do comp compar
the vast majority and now she's just
saying us as across the okay but if we
do make the distinction between genders
in your opinion what are some big issues
with men today that are leading them to
be as you put it
toxic like said the lack of wanting to
commit as this is one of the first thing
that came in my mind cuz I feel like if
we have to dig into the subject it's a
whole subject with a lot of so so what
else is there commitment that that's
something you see as a problem I mean I
can definitely agree that commitment at
least among my generation is something
that is declining but what's
specifically something that you've seen
you you use the term earlier you know
toxic masculinity what's some problems
that you've seen with that what is it
that you don't like about that about
what did he not pay on the first did you
not open your door we're trying to
protect our we just want to know what's
toxic Behavior to you what
you can you I need to hear the question
again what's toxic to
you
um the thing is that I personally don't
want to go into that discussion tonight
cuz I don't I just don't haveg no it's
it's fine it's fine it's fine but likeon
can we ask the men what's for you guys
second one second to be honest I
actually I like I get where you're
coming from and when you say men don't
want to commit or not just men in
general people are having a problem
committing it's actually true this
generation most men are not going to
commit there's nothing to to women but I
want to point out something
that that really directly contradicts
with what you were saying earlier
because now you're saying men don't want
to commit which is fair and which is
kind of true but then earlier you were
saying stuff like uh well if people want
to do only fans it's okay it's this and
that how on I never said it false
statement you were saying you were
saying you were you weren't like there's
you don't have a problem with it or
whatever however you put it but we we I
said it this thisal I'm not saying I'm
not saying it exactly how you said it
but you have you have to say it exactly
for it to be a statement that I said you
need to see exactly what one second one
second my point is my point is what
we're talking about you agreed with
ideology second my point is when we're
talking about promiscuity you didn't
categorically stand against it that's my
point so if I you didn't I did now we
can watch you back see we can let's do
it actually now one
second don't deril the conversation
don't deril the convers I'm ready for it
I
know excuse me excuse me can you guys
can you guys stop can can you guys stop
don't dero the conversation my point is
you were trying to make excuses for it
you didn't you didn't come out like
obviously when I talked about I was like
it is bad we asked you time and time is
it good or bad you kept hoing defense
you didn't want to make a definite
answer I do not agree I believe that
you're talking about somebody else
that's not me and she plead in the my
point is my point is how on Earth are
men meant to commit to women that cannot
even determine what Mr I'm not sure
you're talking about me cuz if it's
about me the statement you're saying
that I made is not a I'm not uh wait
wait wait one second look I don't have
any problem what you're doing right now
you know why you're literally just going
to give us millions of views with what
you're doing because people are going
people yes you can be happy about it and
this is this is the problem with Society
women women women are willing to do
whatever for clout but the point is but
I'm not doing anything for cl you are
misunderstanding me all the time can you
can you let me finish and stop
interrupting me you can but stop also
making stop talking to the wrong person
cuz you are making facts that I never
said so I cannot talk to you since the
facts doesn't
address getting a bit
boring one second can you stop
interrupting me please if you do it
again we will just ask you to leave the
point is yes literally if you interrupt
me one more time you would leave um the
point I'm trying to make is you've
literally contradicted yourself back to
back and even now that I'm calling you
out on it you are still trying to hold
moral High Ground as if you are so sure
that you haven't done it and the reality
is going to be cut into Clips I trust
the people that watch our show they
going to cut you into clips and you're
going to go viral okay just be ready for
it I promise you and if you think I'm
line when you get home go back and watch
it and I I you probably wouldn't even
still understand it by them but maybe by
time you see yourself on Tik Tok in one
million views you understand do anything
for
clout well I just want to know if you
have a standpoint in anything you know
because you've been too Melancholy on
anything I just want to know like what's
your stance on this now you're saying
the show goes out everyone can see it so
we can all watch this back afterwards
and see who said what when they said it
and said [__] so another question that I
wanted to ask you guys um we we were
talking about body count and and Body
Count matters and obviously we're
talking about the topic of of
promiscuity how many bodies makes a
woman
[__] oh [__] God damn God damn it I'm
not going to answer cuz it's just I
don't know how do you answer that
just by answering it by giving a a
number or a number range or makes a
[__] mhm number wise I mean I mean I
saw a study if we're all agreeing that
aore is an extremely promiscuous woman
oh [__] whoever's watching can we can we
put out a number please because I need
but we do realize that question I need
them to answer based on themselves we
just agreed so never know apparently on
average isn't it about seven Partners
yeah but we just
partn for women I don't know I Googled
it the other day this is a very personal
question I don't know if there's
actually if we Google what number makes
I don't think we're going to get a
number
gole in your opinions what number is a
number is an indication that a woman is
overly promiscuous
overly La so to constitute being what a
lot of people would call a [__] ho yeah
ho ho
um should we start from you guys because
again this comes into the question of
you know do women be are women honest
with each other because ultim Li we all
Li wa wa wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait can we can tell each other okay
you're getting fat yeah can we tell each
other you're being a [__] so can you
imagine a friend asking her friend how
many people have you [__] think
they're going to tell the truth but
women see things that happens so women
who go out with each other all the time
they can see how many times their friend
is going home with someone unless you're
slow yeah I think in this day and age
year it's gone up I think it's probably
about I'd say for women a [__] could be
minimum
15 anything about two hands yeah so
we've actually Googled how many sexual
partners does a woman have to make her a
[__] what is an acceptable number of
sexual partners between eight Partners
is considered an average number of
sexual partners for adult men and women
and this is from the 13th of March
2023 so that's what the internet says
can we do can we do some self-reflection
what but in any would you would you
classify yourself outside of this realm
that doesn't say hold up right now who
you asking everyone just the panel in
general would you would you classify
yourself outside of I don't need to give
my personal information out I'm confused
we came to a podcast to talk about this
stuff she she's a dark we came to talk
about I we can start from the men I
defitely a that's I don't know about
you about
Mez I don't know but I know him I know
he come on hold on hey stay safe
[Laughter]
man can you not love so close to
the I've only been with about 25
girls only but why do we need to even
like publicize this is such a personal
thing in my opinion yeah I'm I'm not
asking for anyone's personal number I'm
asking what to you but thank you Romeo
for sharing thank you set himself up
shut himself in the foot I saw he told
me about 62
wait
moving never seen
this he
is can you stop laughing so close to the
mic I a
[__] okay so you you considered a ho in
a man equivalent no we're talking about
women specifically because it is more
harmful for a woman to have multiple sex
no but right now we're talking about the
women so let's stick to the topic of
conversation we're talking about women
because it is a fact that for women
being promiscuous is more harmful than
it is for a man so we're going to stick
to women you said 15
H I think anything over two hands is a
bit of a problem I don't know what you
mean by by that where exactly if I if
you have to count your over 10 so 15 10
huh liberate you know you know you know
you know when we was in school and we
had to do the mental math thing and we
were doing the multiplication thing and
we were doing the if if you got and
simple times that's it my yeah you've
got two on the panel remember that you
kind of have to dumb things you are you
man don't understand the [__] talk
normally that's it oh my bad sorry she's
not real BL gentrification I'm joing
what what
Abola wait wait
abiola to R how how did you pronounce my
name abiola does that not your name no
no what's your name Iola Iola you know
how many bodies constitutes a woman
being a [__] well I'm not going to
argue on though uh here we go again
nobody's a [__] let's go [__] 60 people
for [__] sake we doing no finish
finish I don't want to argue with that
so I'm just going to give a silly a
number cuz I don't understand the topic
so I'm just going to go for hundreds you
don't understand what makes a person a
ho she said I don't 100 buddies man them
stay safe in it that's what I'm saying
man
that's it's a cool world out there man
hey that's triple digits it's a hard
question three of them but if you have
to give it a
metric how much is too much that it
would be
concerning what I'll probably say like
what huh not for her let her
speak I kind of agree with him like the
minimum 50 I'll push it to like I don't
know like he said 15 15 15 15 sorry
15 no 15 oh my good the way you just
turn red right now you just last that
for a second like yeah like 15 20 okay
pushing
up I would say between 15 and 20 okay so
if you know for a fact that your friend
say you guys have been going out like
out on the town or whatever you do
realize can I just say something there's
people that pass the point of going out
and giving a [__] about friends you have
to give a [__] about yourself I'm
talking about for my own personal
expence I'm giving you all the benefit
of the doubt here that you're fairly
good people and you would like
absolutely I can be I can be good not
need validation to have other people
around me to give me that validation
right but if you're surrounded by good
people you trust their opinion but when
you're good enough you trust your own
opinion no I completely disagree with
that I agree but that's why I'm a bit
older than you no offense but when you
reach a certain level where you actually
understand you have that conf not in an
arrogant way no because I'm I'm I'm not
saying I've gradually J mean become no I
still disagree with you it's fine my
point is is that if you are surrounded
by good people people you're going to
trust their opinion so for example op
others brought up age but you just
brought up a point of age okay so if
your mother says something to you you're
going to trust your opinion before your
mother's no I trust my mother's opinion
cuz she's out of age so why would I
trust the opinion of myself knowing I'm
20 years old and 30 years old there's a
big difference right but you just said
that once you get to a certain age you
TR your for anyone else
exactly but you don't reach that
confidence until you are at a certain
age that you understand that I didn't
understand that when I was 23 or
25 right but do you understand what I'm
saying I understand that you're saying
you didn't understand that 23 and now
I'm 30 now I know my own opinion and I
trust my opinion then I didn't that's
the difference so you can never be wrong
she's saying she's old my point that's
my point that you're essentially saying
that once you reach a certain point of
experience yes that you you only trust
your own feelings and opinions of the
world how are you going to learn and
progress in life if you think that when
you reach a certain point you know
everything as a starter point of course
you're going to have friends and family
but you're limited right that's my point
that's exactly what I'm saying you're
supposed to be surrounded by people who
you can trust that they have your best
interests at heart that when they say
something my the only reason my reting
I'm not disagreeing what you're saying
I'm just saying you're leading on more
towards valid having validation of
external factors no no no you presumed
that and you inferred that onto what I
said that's not what I'm saying we
actually agree validation validation is
different from from trusting other
people's opinion
valid people
valid this is why I asked for a metric
on the topic of horse because the
question that I'm trying to pose to you
guys is are you going to tell your
friend if she's being a [__] hey I'm
not going to lie I feel like the number
I I feel like the numbers that everyone
gave out was a way of separating
themselves from whoredom I could be
potentially wrong I could be potentially
wrong but I feel like what everyone
resumed on this stage and again I'm
talking to both men and women on this
stage so please don't be upset I think
everyone gave numbers that made
themselves look good I agree because I I
I personally would have said five even
though I know I'm way past that number
because I'm I'm I don't I don't have
this hubris to not be able to see where
I'm wrong as well just because I say
five is the number doesn't mean I can't
accept the fact that I am well past that
number but that's the problem a lot of
women have even though once they have P
something they they they they seem to
almost think like if they agree to the
truth then they almost shooting
themselves in the foot so I get what
you're saying I get what you're saying
hey it goes It goes back to what I said
at the start I feel like they just Chang
can you ask what you just wanted to ask
me again would you tell your friend if
she's being [__] yeah mhm same thing as
fat cuz I think obviously the
conversation went somewhere else
absolutely I think it comes from a
concerned place but again us being
delusional within ourselves we can then
be delusional within other friends right
from from like the female perspective
now when do you become TR is it more
easier for us to be truthful towards
ourselves or towards others cuz we can
be in deny more towards ourselves than
actually the exteral the friends family
whatever whoever's around
us yeah both both what do you think the
would you tell them yeah yeah 100% has
anyone actually been in a situation
where they've had to tell before you
call Cap yeah I have actually been in a
situation
that how did that go how did that go
like obviously again I'm I wasn't
straight out like you're a [__] no but
I was like look you might be one you
you've been you've been moving a bit mad
lately like how do you even say it by
the way wait wait wait wait car like
you're moving mad a bit like this com
from Place concern I'm not judging you
in any sense like this is at the end of
the day this is what you want to do but
I'm just telling you and how did that
friend react she was like she took it
well like she wasn't upset she knew that
I was coming from a good place she knew
that I wasn't sat there trying to like
trying to you know shame her like I was
did she change her
behavior no no so you told her she was
spreading Community cheeks and she just
accepted it like that and just kept
spreading Community cheeks if they if
they choose to do that her fault that's
not my fault I'm I'm I'm not saying it
is I just wanted to I just wanted some
more clarification you told her she was
spreading Community cheeks and she just
did more and she she's still considered
what she wanted to do that's the same
telling someone oh you're you're getting
weight you're gaining weight and then
still choosing to eat KFC and McDonald
listen more power to them man hey big up
them boy there you get me yeah but
what's what's the issue with this thing
where people say um I'm not judging you
or I don't want them to feel like you
are absolutely supposed to judge your
friends like what what's this thing a
women are so obsessed with oh I don't
want to judge her I don't want to and it
goes back to what I was saying women are
not really friends with each other not
real because the reality is among among
my guy friends I don't have a lot of guy
friends but the very few friends I have
if I'm doing some Madness they're
absolutely going to call me out on it
and judge me for it how many years have
you had worst possible way ever how many
years you had them for for like for a
very long time so absolutely going to
judge me and tell me bro what the hell
are you doing get your [__] right in
fact there there are times where and
this is something this is among guys if
if when when we're coming up as kids and
we want to go out obviously we're going
out to go and meet girls and all if you
dress in some weird way you're not going
out with us bro go back home and change
bro like go back home and change girls
will allow their friends to C yeah girls
girls won't girls won't tell their
friends in the mini dress that is not
Min takes
one the the boys will even take you back
to your house and wait outside for you
make sure you change go out listen I
think friendship has changed completely
it depends on your culture no I just
don't think women have the same frenches
as men well that's why I get along with
like personally like I have more guy
friends that I get along with cuz it's
more simple black and white chill women
are very over complicated why did you
not do this why did you not do that like
the most simplest dumbest little things
and I understand that because we're
wired unfortunately like that but even
friendships these days regardless of men
and women what is what makes somebody a
friend these days cuz everybody walks
with uh intent to gain do you know let
me ask you little question yeah because
I can I can almost guarantee if I ask
every man in this in this room right
here they can say at least on one hand
they probably got maybe two to three
friends that they've known for like the
longest if you've had the same friends
over 10 years you're not real in my
opinion
par what huh
that's what are you talking about more
than like a group a group sorry not just
one individual if you've got the same
group of people let's say five to to 10
people average if you've got the same
five to 10 people and you're still
rolling and doing the same [__] you've
not grown in my opinion one or two
people they you've known for over 10
years 15 years maybe but if you've got
the same people you've not grown my love
you why no no no no let her explain why
and then I I will let you guys go why
why why do you why do you hold that
opinion because every single individual
is unique every single person is going
to have different interests so you're
going to naturally divert to a different
gr grow apart in it grow apart but that
doesn't mean a bad thing it's not like
I'm doing better than you but we all go
through life lessons at different points
in life right you might have more trauma
at a younger AG I might have more TR at
a later age we're all designed
differently our PS are going to be
different if you've got the same
[__] around you for and you've
got more than five of them in your group
my love you've not you've not achieved
anything in life less people that you
have no there's less no no I'm sorry but
real reality reality is those five
people are not going to be doing and
thinking the same way as you there's
always going to be one person that's a
bit more advanced or walking in a
different direction in my opinion if
you're all sugar coating crap to be like
yeah yeah you're good you're good to one
another You' you've not evolved in my
opinion the reality is you don't really
like you can't even really have like 10
real friends anyways so that your point
is is kind of no but when you're 15
years old and when you're 30 years old
you go through a shift if you've got the
same friends at 20 and the same
individuals at 30 you can you can have
one or two lifelong friends yeah one or
two yeah but You' got five she's talking
about a group yeah but no one was
talking about who has a group of friends
for their whole life
anyway cool cap I got the same group of
friends six people for about from since
we was in primary school and we've all
gr who's jealous of who and who's done
more than who's giving of
who on nobody's jealous I'd love to all
of you you know what get all your
friends let's sit down we have a
conversation we definitely do that see
who's who do you want do you want to
know what I'll tell you uh first of all
none of us are jealous of each other
because we hold each other accountable
one minute we all hold each other
accountable if one of my brons is
sitting down either overweight broke or
your hairline isn't being done by the
correct bar but I'm going to tell you
Bloods we're Breen we're Mand
them we're far gone from the days where
we used to be on the playground and we
used to back each other and we used to
do all this kind of stuff we're big men
now but why don't you want to be sitting
with somebody that's done more and
bigger than you to get influence instead
of sitting down with the same people for
the last first of first of all that's a
woman's way of what I'm saying first of
all a business first of all what you're
no first of all different from what I'm
saying first of all what you're talking
about is what the person can do for me
I'm not worrying about what my can do
for me exactly my Breen are here to be
my brethren if I'm doing something
that's absolute Madness I expect you as
one of my brr to hold Fu accountable to
what the whole conversation was about we
were talking about if a real friend will
tell you if you're fat or ugly or
whatever the hell it is to say it in
your face but then if you're not
achieving your full is potential isn't
that the same thing oh I'm not going to
lie I don't know what question just just
asked saying the question that we all we
were talking about was would you tell
your friend if they're fat would you
tell I I said that I said that from yes
long time ago so we can we can entie
that same thing as somebody knowing your
full potential but I might be
intimidated but I might not tell you
what your full potential is to see you
grow so that sounds like that person
isn't your Breen and that's not the
people that's not the people I'm talking
about some's
interior no no what you're talking about
is you're talking about your friendships
from your point of view time what time
what time okay in general you're talking
about everybody else's friendships from
everybody else's point of view that has
variety of people everyone's
self-centered no one's real with one
another this is my point no even friends
AR with one another going to allow me to
finish before you cut me off baby no one
Qui you off carry on talking
don't you cut me off like three Vic you
cut me off like three times when I was
actually trying to make a well I think
she likes you you know probably you know
it's a bit crazy I'm I'm not single
anyway anyway I'm breaks sounds like
your problem sounds like a your problem
anyway what I'm trying let me startop
crying now sounds like your problem
anyway what I'm trying to say is it
sounds like you don't have real friends
broken it sounds like you don't have
real friends because again no matter the
situation that I'm in with theand them
and I'm pretty sure 10 years old bab but
okay we're going to sit down and we're
going to wait for adults to have some
decorum because clearly when someone is
making a point nobody can just sit back
and relax look at everyone I look in
eyes you're going to talk to me inid I
look over you over here so why are you
making things up friend my friend can
you just listen to the point as all
right all right let me let me let me let
me allow her to finish it's clear her
body count is over 15 but that's the
only reason why she gave the [__] out
like what we doing here please it man
I'm giv I'm giving you doesn't that
doesn't mean anything to me I'm giving
you respect me the
same giv you respect giv me the same
respect simple guys wait finish allow a
man to finish do you have the do Hello
can we stop can you let him finish thank
you I have I didn't you didn't you cut
me off like five times just every time
he's speaking you just have to say
something just let him finish we're not
against each other we're just making
points like we don't need to long story
short listen if you if you've got over a
certain amount of friends and you can't
handle those people it sounds like a you
problem I've had the same five to six
friends for about 20 years we all went
to the same PR School nobody in my
friendship group is fat nobody in my
friendship group is broke nobody in my
friendship group is a deadbeat dad
nobody in my friendship group is just a
dead beat in general do you want to know
why because I don't allow the mandm
around me to be degenerate I don't allow
the manum to sit down and be [__]
and be doing things that I just
genuinely don't accept for myself that's
why I'm saying our friendships are
different mhm you see what I'm saying
you're turn around to me and tell me oh
if you have a certain amount of friends
over 20 no you're chatting [__] it just
has to your a bad friend brother I've
had the same brigin from since I came
just just after I came to this country
and I went to school at like 9 years old
I've had the same brends and we all hold
each other [__] accountable think
Howell are you going to come come and
turn around to me and tell me what you
talking about I hear what you're saying
I I think it's really interesting to to
highlight that perhaps there is a
difference between male friendships and
female friendships and this is
definitely something I've seen I mean
we've all established that we can agree
that there is a degree of lying that
goes on in female friendships females
lie to each other and I do think it's
really interesting what you said about
you you you argued it's a business
perspective perhaps uh in a business
context you know you might surround
yourself with people who are doing their
business is doing better than yours
because you want your business to
succeed but you you did apply it to
friendships and you said that you like
to surround yourself with people who are
doing better than you because you want
to emulate their success no that emulate
emulate is is another word learn right
you want to learn whatever it is that
they know that you don't and that's why
they're more successful and let them
criticize me instead of people that
aren't really a level where I'm at right
but that is a very female thing to do
you know that's is hypergamy essentially
it's you know the fact that we we date
across and above and from what it sounds
like you're saying is that you you pick
and choose your friends on that same
basis and I think that's the point that
he was trying to make is that him and
his friends are just friends because
they've been associated with each other
since they were you said nine Primary
School right and and they've held each
other to a level that they've been able
to come up together um I think where the
conversation got a bit derailed is when
you made the statement of if you've got
more than MH 10 friends quite a certain
amount of time yeah right
so I I I just want to understand like
why why it is that you've come to to
that conclusion you know obviously I you
would imagine at least that because
you're saying it is because you've had
some kind of personal experience like
that is that the case for you I mean
it's it's it is reality when you look at
it listen you're not going to be the
same person from a certain age let's say
within 10 years but neither are those
people so they could be changing as well
Absol but absolutely but the thing is
our day-to-day lives our interests our
mentality our knowledge or shape our
social aspect right so if you're going
to sit down with the same people and in
each individual might not understand one
another there's going to be more
conflict involved there's going to be
less exchange of the same all those
individuals still have their own
individual lives outside of the
Friendship they canar unfortunately the
reality is most that might be your
reality but we've just got a guy right
here who's saying actually no his
reality is that the same but I don't see
that as growth in my opinion that's just
my own opinion not saying it's right or
wrong so you're saying we haven't grown
is that what you're saying in my opinion
no yeah okay and you know you're
entitled to your opinion but listen a
lot of infal people if you read a lot of
people not necessarily in the business
aspect more even in a normal
psychological aspect if you're resigning
with the same thing at a certain age and
the same thing after let's say 10 years
15 years it's not in my opinion it's not
considered as growth okay and that's
fine and I I'm not talking about one or
two people yes it's a normal thing to
have one or two people that you've grown
up with I'm saying if you're surrounded
by the same environment the same group
of people going to the same places doing
the same thing and the same job I mean
the repetition I don't see that as
growth okay I'll say two things that
sounds like a lack of accountability
because if you're in the same place
because of the people around you like a
you problem you're blessed to have
people around you for all those years
number two it sounds like you're just a
bad friend not necessarily you but just
in general for for the point you're
saying if you don't have a good amount
of long-term friends it just sounds like
you're a bad friend you can't blame me
for having the same amount of friends
from primary school um and we've all
grown up we're all a lot of us are
fathers all with the partners all doing
well all have businesses all of the man
them are doing
good like you can't turn around to me
and tell me that's not a good thing or
that
I haven't grown because of that
situation in general all I'm saying is I
feel like you need to equate what you're
saying to maybe your
situation or or or may or maybe what we
should do is we should just stop making
absolute statements and just speak for
yourself because when you speak for
yourself it what you're saying might
resonate to a lot more people than
opposed to saying that this is happening
with more than 51% of the people that
you're talking about always remember
that when we're we're making these
points if it's not more than
51% if you can't quantify that it's more
than 51% don't say most don't say all
don't say any of these sweeping
statements just speak about yourself so
I I have a question so um what was the
metric you used was it 10 years if
you've been friends with the same people
from 20 to 30 right so uh I'm not I'm
saying the group not one or two people
no the group right okay so you said
you're 30 you're 30 okay and and how
many friends would you say are in your
sort of immediate friendship
group friends or acquaintances because
friends about five about five so in 10
years are you going to bin those five
people off yeah if I don't see the same
oh that's resolution of morals and why
of life and if I can't resonate to you
with my own basic morals and basic way
of life and basic way of thought yeah of
course that's going to be conflict have
you gotten along with people that have
different political opinions you going
to yeah one of my closest friends is a
massive shout out to Hannah you annoy
the [__] out of me but you get along but
this this is a new example which is
brilliant but unfortunately older
generations for some reason people
disconnect because of religious
political whatever Financial views
that's unfortunately we can't CU I I
don't disagree with people just breaking
up a friendship for the sake of having
different opinions that's the opposite
of what I'm saying but I'm saying the
reality that's
become the reaction between
people I don't I'm not a fake person to
be around somebody just for the sake of
having a friend people are going to
change just cuz I'm not friends with
somebody doesn't mean it's a negative
thing doesn't mean I hate you and I've
told you to get out of my life
everyone's Direction goes in different
paths that's my point that's what I'm
trying to say no I get what you're
saying and I and I completely agree you
know people change over time people's
morals change people's life philosophies
change people people grow and evolve but
the problem that I have is just with the
statement that you know you haven't
grown if you still have the same friends
for 10 years because you know group not
friends group sorry I correct myself
group group of people it just concerns
me because you know you you said you
have these five friends
now well if you're following your own
logic that means in in 10 years you
you're going to have to get rid of them
because you just said it's inevitable
that people will change over 10 years
yeah but when I'm 40 years old we're not
going to be doing the same things I am
going to be doing today right so why
would I resonate with the same probably
not going to be friends with them in 10
years who knows I hope so but everyone's
life goes in different directions
right that's mad how many drinks you had
man the thing I just find funny about
what you're saying is like I get it that
people change and people grow but that's
why I'm I'm hoping for the best I'm
talking my point is the only reason why
I would bend someone off as a friend is
if they are growing in a negative
Direction yes exactly no but that's not
what you said you said people but
there's a reason why I've gotten rid of
people because of that reason no but my
point is the way you framed it that's
where the problem lies you said you said
if if because you initially made like
you said a very sweeping statement like
people grow and people change so if
you're with the same people over 10
years then obviously that doesn't
signify growth which is weird because
the reality is you guys can actually
grow and you might not even have the
same ideologies but that doesn't mean
you can't still be friends the only
reason why you probably will not be
friends with someone is if maybe they
growing in a negative Direction that's
different from them growing in a
different direction someone can grow in
a different direction and we can still I
think I phrased myself wrong because
when I met yeah like in my opinion
people that I've G rid of is because
they've gone through they've gone
towards more of a negative thing so when
I mean growth I mean you're either
resonating with somebody or you're not
yeah so I I I think you should actually
what I mean when you're not I mean in a
negative aspect yeah so you should
actually lead with the fact that you
lose friendships when people grow
that not that you are in inevita going
to become inevita inevitably not going
to be friends with people after a
certain number of years that doesn't
make sense because of yeah what you just
said you've just framed it
perfectly well that's good that we will
manag to reach
W um uh on the the topic of of women and
and promiscuity in in my opinion
something that's going to have a
negative impact on you this this whole
conversation stemmed from the question
of what makes a woman a wh I think it's
going to have a negative impact on you
once you have over five bodies and I
have that basis on the fact that women
struggle to pair bond uh significantly
after they have had five sexual partners
so that's my personal opinion everyone
else has their own numbers I think it's
a the numbers that have been given and
perhaps maybe more accustomed to the
current climate I don't know but the
that's my my personal take on that so if
at the moment we know that you know
women are sleeping around a lot more and
promiscuity has
increased what are Men supposed to
expect from women in the modern day and
age you know what what could we all
agree on as some factors that would make
a good
wife because we spoke about commitment
and we said how that is disappearing I
mean some might argue that there's a
correlation between the fact that women
are much more promiscuous now and
perhaps maybe that's why men don't want
to commit because they're they're
worried that this promiscuous behavior
isn't going to stop so I want to hear
from each of you what are some things
that you think makes a good wife that to
clarify you would a man you care about
in your life your father your son your
granddad your uncle whoever you you
would see these characteristics in a
woman and you would go yeah I I think
that's wife
material I let you answer question
I think a woman who just generally cares
about her family just the way that she
you you view her and see how she treats
her family is just I think that's a
clear indicator how she'll treat yours
so Family Values yeah 100% Family Values
what else I think obviously the I think
loyalty plays a massive part in it um we
touched base about you know commitment
and I think you
know and being non committ is obviously
you're not really wanting to be loyal to
someone so I think 100% you have to be
loyyal in a relationship I think Loy is
very rare in modern day so how can a so
I I agree 100% of course but how can a
man discern if a woman is loyal or not
because some men might look at a woman
who has say s with two people and say
she's probably going to be loyal to me
but they might look at a woman who slept
with say 30 people and say chances are
she's probably not going to be loyal to
me that's what I I know from hearing men
say but in in your opinion you know how
how can a man tell if a woman's loyal or
not I think it's just through her
actions like I I think a lot of the
times people just listen to the words
and never really actually view the
actions and I completely understand what
you're saying like you you may assume
that someone who's got two buddies may
be more loyal than someone that's got 30
but that's probably not the case so I
think in the sense it's just the way her
actions are towards you and very much so
like yeah as I as I said but isn't isn't
the number of people she slept with part
of her actions yeah but these are the
people that she's in a relationship with
like these may be just people that she's
just having having fun with that's the
point
because I find it funny when like when
people separate loyalty to only when
they're in a relationship for you to be
loyal I I I don't think it's it's easy
for someone that had many partners to be
loyal because that just means that you
you prioritize your own personal
pleasure over actually taking care of
other
people yeah so we we know for a fact
that uh women who who sleep around and
have more sexual partners they the
numbers for them are a lot higher in
things like divorce the the happiness in
their relationships is a lot less um so
actually it is a bit of a fact that the
higher your body count the less likely
you are to to be loyal so would you say
that body count comes into wife
material again you can you can you can
hear my facts you don't have to say that
you want to make your judgment off of
that I'm just asking for for you and for
say a guy that you you care about I'm
talking like a family member they come
to you and they say look I'm thinking
about proposing to This Woman This is
who she is you know is that something
that would make a difference to you yeah
you know if if if my brother came up to
me and was like oh like I've got mes but
she's her body counts mad crazy I
BL I think I think yeah you you you'll
pause and have a bit of a but what if he
loves her
then don't put me on the spot like that
okay so you you've said Family Values
loyalty body count anything
else I think just always just being a
good person overall I think like just
having having broad statement what just
what constitutes a good person like just
having you know good good good morals
like just being being respectful like I
think respect is a massive thing as well
and not just the people that you're very
intimate and close with but just respect
in a whole General aspect with other
people like I don't really see today
people keeping the door open for other
people people holding the elevator
people helping someone men don't do that
anymore because women bite their heads
off when they do it wait
whatmore a lot of men won't open the
door for women anymore because there's
been numerous stories where women have
absolutely bitten men's heads off I
remember one of my old bosses held the
door never heard that I've heard it a
lot one of my old bosses actually held
the door open for someone once and uh
this woman just completely ripped into
him was like you think I can't open the
door for myself what you think because
I'm a woman you need to open the door
for I would just walked away like if you
can't take my courtesy I would have just
walked away what you what I agree with
you I actually think I actually think
men that don't do that anymore are are
the weak men we speak about because the
reality is it don't matter if women have
completely lost their mind if you've
been raised right as a man you're still
going to be who you are so if I were to
open the door for a woman and she's
ratting off I I'll probably just say
something nasty to her and walk away or
I'll that's on a bad day but on a good
day I'll probably just even ignore her
and just walk away but it's not going to
stop me from opening the door for the
next person no I I I agree it is
definitely something that shouldn't die
out my point is is that it is dying out
and and I think that that's potentially
a reason why um but yeah respect I I
completely agree with you so you've said
we'll go for one more let's go for five
so you've said respect Family Values
loyalty body count and you said good
morals but it's a I want to know what
constitutes good morals so respect great
good um so what can a woman do that that
makes her wife material to a
guy sted can I pass a son what she wants
to pH a friend what makes five things
that make a good wife five things so
what what have I said respect you've
said respect Family Values loyalty and
body count so far and I said loy oh yeah
I did say loyalty already yeah yeah yes
you got one more left now you put me on
a spot I can't actually
think I don't know being a good cook I
don't know man [__] you mean no I don't
know a little something something guys I
come to know guys cuz I I want to know
what what women think makes a a good
wife versus what what men think actually
I'm actually stuck on this that's okay
we can pass it
on so easy I will let the man speak
first and
then she always does
this oh bro you first
um caring warm uh good personality um
supportive as well as um one more thing
I would
say um strong because like physically
strong emotionally strong with oh no no
just just emotionally strong because
like you just have to go through a lot
when you have kids obviously I'm not I'm
not speaking from a place where there's
like a single parent household I'm
speaking a place where you're there's
both parents in a household that type of
thing in general you have to be strong
like sleeping sleepless nights um taking
care of the kids
discipline um so the qualities that
would make a good a good mother someone
who's nurturing someone who who's caring
and some who has the strength to to see
that out okay what makes a good wife all
right good
personality so someone you can get along
with yeah good sex right sex is like
it's up there it has to be like it's
very very important but at the same time
considering her body count right
considering her body count yes but I
don't need body count cuz she she she's
already said it so that's I didn't even
say it personality sex she knows how to
cook Y and need a woman that can cook
not saying that I can't cook I'm just
saying we both need to cook um she has
to have a good sense of
humor yeah talking about me
huh and she has she has to have a good
set of
teeth okay yeah interesting one
interesting
one okay so you're the last person no
second to last person to answer this
question uh what makes a good wife if
you had to break it down into five
things uh say you I don't know do you
have a brother I have a brother yeah
okay your brother comes to you and says
I've got this girl I'm I'm thinking
about proposing what's five things that
you want to hear This Woman's got I mean
like the guys were mentioning I think
basic things like cooking and cleaning
and my opinion that's an empowerment for
a woman because like that's a woman
makes a home a like a house a home sorry
a woman makes groceries into a food you
I mean into a meal like we we add that
that feminine energy and I think when a
woman is in her own feminine energy it's
very beautiful but it takes a man to let
her be in her feminine energy I think
that's when a woman's vulnerable not
vulnerable in that sense that we think
is a negative thing I think
vulnerability can be misconstrued in
many ways I think when a woman feels
relaxed and in her own feminine energy
she can create okay so cooking cleaning
cooking cleaning and must one of the
majority like one of the most specific
things in my opinion is a woman that's
in tuned with emotions and reality so if
she sees her man come home from work she
nurturing nurturing but not but not not
necessarily just nurturing cuz nurturing
can imply two different things I think
in tune okay being in tune to reality
circumstances
emotions okay so I'm going to say
nurturing so she knows how to nurture a
man if he needs her emotional support so
she can cook clean she's nurturing two
more listen as well listening is a big
thing women have a problem with with
listening in my opinion agree cuz it's
very defensive it's very like I me I'm
this like we all lead from ego
unfortunately and men and women like we
all kind of like the reason why conflict
happens I think because we lead ego can
come from pain as well by the way and
Trauma so we all react from like let's
say somebody has mentioned a specific
subject we as an individual as a person
not men women we might react because of
our own
experience okay so last one
loving can I add Independence cuz I only
had four can I add Independence as well
so if your brother came to you and said
that he he has a girl who he's thinking
about proposing to you you would like to
know that she's independent yeah as as
yeah what do you mean independent mean
financially independent like what do you
mean what does that look like so for me
independent like in the sense that like
she won't just dump her whole world on
him like she still is able to stand on
her own because as but that's more
vulnerable how no as you said how like
women go through a lot of emotions like
s s this and that so she needs to be
able to hold her own and not and be able
to look after the household I would I is
what you're saying emotionally stable
what you say you can't what wait what
you say let her finish you can't look
after the household we can I'm saying
the EM stability oh yeah emotionally
stable but like also like in yeah
emotionally stable so not to emotionally
depend on the husband yes okay yeah
that's a good one actually I I I agree
with that I think uh women too often go
into relationships with the idea that
the man is supposed to fix all of her
problems um and I and I think that
actually know a lot of your problems are
your own and that a partner is there to
help you get through them yourself um a
partner isn't going to be ever be the
answer for you so the last why will and
jader is in the same place yeah as a for
me that's a weird dynamic by the way
that's a weird we haven't got time for
that one today guys I'm sorry one of the
most important thing for me I will start
with um principle and
values I would think I would say that
it's something important when a woman
have a principle of values I will also
agree on the great listener nurturing
and uh another important thing for me is
a woman who is comfortable in her
feminine
energy and yeah one more that's four for
CH yeah why ain't any of you that just
said like a woman that back like a demon
there can you just thank me for saying
that by the way yeah big you come on the
last point would be a woman who is in
touch with her intuition which which is
femininity do you eat the box of course
I
do sorry whatat the bo eat the Box
vagina the vagina the vagina vag you is
that what you qu it these days the let
her give her last characteristic sorry I
already give everything now OB everybody
was talking in there but we're talking
about more important things like the Box
no no no her let her carry on yeah I
believe I already said what I need to
say I talked about principle and Val
politics you know Jesus
Christy principal and valleys I get all
the time cut off as you can see guys no
no no carry on carry on car so yeah I
talk about principal
and values principle and
values femininity I'm done cuz uh she's
finished interesting every time that I'm
talking there's somebody that needs to
say something I don't think I found
particularly interesting and I think we
kind of alluded to it here with uh the
the point of listening it was kind of
alluding to it um but what I found
really interesting is that no one said
the ability to obey and submit and the
reason I bring this up is because
actually it was part of marriage vows so
you've got you know till death to us
part uh for richer for poor and ask me
you didn't ask me my own I'm so sorry I
totally forgot let's get back to
King ask ask King man what you saying
come on but that's a part of our
feminine energy femininity is to obey in
my opinion for me it's I have very 2023
specific um values because we live in a
crazy time y so one it has to be a woman
who has mental fortitude to stand
against the crazy times we live in so
for instance my kids cannot be
fat my kids cannot be sold into this
stupid gender identity politics all that
crap king would you would you allow your
kids to go to social let me finish
please so if if there's anything coming
up with all these problems where my kids
are asking those questions she has to be
the kind of woman that tells them this
is right this is wrong that is the most
important thing in 2023 for me because
we live in a time where the
government Society is just trying to
chatter our kids like cattle and just
use them and use them for their agenda
so she has to be a woman that
understands right from wrong there has
there's no standing on the
fence that's one number two she has to
be a woman that like you said
obeys so she has to understand that I am
the head of the family and I make the
final decisions but King is changing now
because a woman who has rightfulness
would think I will never take my
personally if I had children when I have
children I wouldn't take them to state
school cuz I don't need them to be
brainwashed and you're you're T I don't
I don't you're talking about a woman
that is L I don't think that's the
problem the problem is not the schools
yeah the schools are part of the problem
the problem is because parents are not
involved in in education at the end of
the day if a child is brought up in a
home where they are equipped with the
right ideologies and the right values
they can go to any school and they're
going to be able to fight off
unfortunately there's more influenced by
schools than because
If the parents have enough influence
that's not going to happen and that's
the the reason why the reason why
there's more influence on kids than the
parents is because we live in a society
of weak people we live in a society
where people can't say what weak minded
you mean one second we live in a society
where people can't say right from wrong
people are too scared to say this
because oh they'll get canceled and all
that crap when I was growing up although
it's not as bad as this now but we had a
lot of weird ideas that we learned from
school but obviously because of the way
we grew up we knew this is obviously
nonsense we can't move along with this
direction and back then it was very easy
to separate you know that okay these are
the crazy people stay away from them but
now it's kind of like oh well we just
have to crazy now yeah's now we used
have a CL for them whoever is going to
in my opinion if you're a good wife you
have to be able to stand your ground and
uphold the family values but do you find
it more attractive a woman that knows
how to cook and clean than a woman that
doesn't H what is it more attractive for
like
men are you more attractive towards a
woman that knows how to cook and clean
and maintain a home than a woman that
doesn't is are the comparison like
different are you more like why
attracted the the main question is for
me personally why why does a woman not
know how to cook and clean exactly
that's the main question why why
Foundation Hey listen listen unless you
grew up Jamaican there is no other
reason for you not to how to and clean
yeah which is the W unless you grew up
Jama there's no other listen the only
Jama listen I grew up I was born I was
put in the kitchen no obviously I'm I'm
a Jamaican man feel like we sh it down a
little bit better than the women in our
community just see what I'm saying like
you don't see the women in the flip
flops and the and the Str vest with JK
and chicken just see what I'm saying you
see the man doing it with the Open Toe
Jesus lip you see this as black and
white or cultural wives by the way
cultur there's women like like me I'm
talking about from my own experience
that we born straight metaphorically
speaking put in a kitchen to have an A a
life that serves the men and the family
which I prer which I prefer by the way
again I was brought up with the British
mentality and the Albanian mentality so
I have both to compare obviously
obviously our cultures are different is
it no they're not they're very simple no
they're different they're different cuz
again put it this way
there is no man on this Earth that's
going to feed you more than Jamaican
man can we just I beg your pardon I'm
sure I'm sure but I'm just saying the JK
chicken the rice and peas the curry gold
the ox the St Peas the planting what are
you talking about what youan well look
guys we're going to cut the
conversations we're going to cut the
conversation that we've been
speaking irrelevant my Jamaicans man my
M trying to talk Jamaican the point is
oh [__] any competent adult in this
world should know how to cook how to
clean fact yes yes I agree especially
all different cultures have all
different foodsan CHS which is lovely
and amazing but no matter where you come
from what part of the world you should
know how to cook and clean and if you
don't unfortunately that to me says that
you are incompetent in control of your
own self as well in control C and clean
is yeah incompetent M so we can all
agree on that look I think uh if you are
going to marry a lady she should
definitely be able to cook and clean I
think that's just a basic competent
adult I think that she should be able to
obey um I think that she should have a
level of obedience to her and we've all
mentioned the qualities that make up
femininity such as nurturing caring
loving um the ability to just kind of
let the man lead and I think that's
something that a lot of modern women
today struggle to do but that's just
what I think why don't you guys let me
know what you thought of this
conversation in the comments before we
close up the show I'm going to hand over
to you all to plug your socials whatever
you want to do king shall we read the
super chats
oh the Super
Chat quiet in superat pleas all right so
I'm going to read the Super Chat and
then we'll close out the show oh [__] um
Death Proof bomb 01 only fans is not a
is not a bad platform Modern Woman Circa
2023 say no more mod woman yeah I he you
sip
no only fans is not a bad platform in
quot yes um is Nei por dog MPA a single
a single mother only fans pimp she's a
demon # demon time who you talking about
say Nam guys let him read guys please
enter black dragon relationships and
marriages will continue to fail until
men and women begin to understand their
biological nature and operate from that
standpoint instead of conforming to
arbitrary Society
standards enter black dragon anyone
believe that marriage is the highest
honor dog MPA baby mama with the wig on
the couch is a demon a snake tonged
longtailed sharp fanged fire breeding
demon guys guys please guys guys please
can you control your yourself um an
exorcism is needed tonight 93 topai men
fear one question I'm waiting for the
what if women fear quotation why the
only way for women to be honest is if
you disguise her voice face location and
can't be
recorded Zango Zango Z Blondie talks too
much enter black d waiting for a blondie
can you please just let me finish enter
black dragon wife equals to woman in
feminine energy 100% in marriage all
right so also blonde had a point yeah uh
um Christine over to you final thoughts
so [__] funny well look final
thoughts uh the topic of today's
conversation was on promiscuity um look
I think if you've come across a
promiscuous woman unfortunately that is
an indication that it's probably not
going to be a successful marriage we
know this from Marriage stats we we know
this from the happiness that women have
in longterm relationships after having a
promiscuous past um so yeah that that's
my final thoughts for today I'm I'm
going to pass it over now guys final
thoughts and of course plug any socials
that you want to
plug uh I just want to say thank you for
having me on uh I just all I wish is
just healing and
love in a general aspect that's what I
want that's going to be my final message
yes thank you again it's been it's been
uh entertaining and
yeah any socials you want to plug oh EMS
arino on
Instagram all right um it was a great
night and uh whatever I said I stand by
it if you didn't understand then you
didn't understand that's not uh really
my problem so yeah my social art IA
adaku yeah thank you very
much A's reactions I'm not going to lie
there's been a hella cap on the panel
I'm not going to lie I'll be honest man
if if we had a good time no I have a
I've had a good time but if we're being
honest I don't think anyone everyone was
very hon the man were honest oh my
God I man honest I feel like this half
of the stage was definitely honest but
I'm just saying you know what I'm saying
do you know what it is you see when we
have these conversations don't come with
like um uh say that say that to yourself
what you're about to say say it to
yourself all right do you know what AJ's
reactions on yeah everything you get me
so no you already know it's your boy
like Romeo the plug official Romeo 27
outside at the just ply things Network
thank you Christina did a great show
yeah yeah you're very welcome thank you
very much for for for joining me today
done already so there you have it that
that's it for today's show um as I said
before I'm a talent here at the audacity
Network so if you like anything I had to
say do go check out my channel um and
check out my series debunk in the lunacy
where I give you the side that the
mainstream media doesn't necessarily
want you to know so if that sounds like
something you'd be into definitely go
check it out um and as always make sure
you hit that subscribe button here on
the just PE things YouTube channel to
stay up to date with all of these live
shows and of course P daily and we will
see you very very soon
soon no h
feelings done
already no a